[Musique]
françoisino bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne YouTube qui
s'appelle Syerview
nous passons d'ailleurs un bonjour à
votre communauté qui nous a chaudement
recommandé mes et meses et meses et main
de fois votre venue chez nous mais on
leur a expliqué qu'on faisait pas les
politiques mais que exceptionnellement
pour 2017 nous allons faire les
présidentes comment allez-vous  ça va
bien mais je peux réagir tout de suite à
ce que vous avez dit allez communauté je
sais pas très bien ce que ça veut dire
nous on a des citoyens français de tous
les horizons je sais qu'il y en a
certains qui sont parfois insistants
très mais c'est pas moi qui le demande
hein c'est pas J'ai pas je ne donne pas
des instructions sur le thème aller
assaillir tel ou tel non non non ce qui
est vrai c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de gens et de plus en plus qui
nous rejoignent et un sentiment
d'extrême
injustice parmi les gens qui découvrent
nos analyses et mes analyses notamment
et mes conférences parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que moi je dis des choses que
ne dit aucun autre responsable politique
et je ne passe dans absolument aucun
grand média audiovisuel vous l'avez vous
l'avez noté donc c'est vous êtes passé
sur on n'est pas couché c'est ça  je
suis passé euh une fois chez TDI mais
c'était il y a 3 ans et encore il m'a
fait il m'a exfiltré au bout de 20 enfin
20 minutes avant la fin en disant je
crois que vous avez un
rendez-vous euh alors il y a des gens
qui m'ont apprêt qui m'ont dit "Mais
enfin président pourquoi vous êtes parti
20 minutes avant la fin  pourquoi vous
aviez pris un rendez-vous ?" J'avais pas
de rendez-vous simplement il m'avait il
m'avait il m'avait fait sortir 20
minutes avant la fin très gentiment
d'ailleurs enfin il était venu retirer
l'oreillette et puis je suis passé
c'était en septembre 2014 donc il y a il
y a 2 ans et et et 3 mois maintenant je
suis passé chez chez Rier à on n'est pas
couché dans une émission qui avait été
enregistrée dans les conditions du
direct c'est-à-dire 55 minutes et puis
le produit final ça été 18 minutes et il
y a eu des coupes qui ont complètement
dénaturé d'ailleurs ce que ce que
j'avais dit voilà c'est C'est les deux
fois où je suis passé chez nous c'est
dans les conditions du direct on ne
coupe pas c'est un one shot on est payé
par personne d'ailleurs on n pas
d'agence de communication qui nous paye
pour faire des interviews pour les
primaires ou je pense à certaines autres
chaînes YouTube donc ici on est 100 %
bénévole et bah c'est comme un UPR 100 %
bénévole et payé par personne voilà on a
le temps de pouvoir délayer certaines
idées on va commencer avec vous vous
êtes notre dernier de la journée et
comme vous étiez à l'heure contrairement
à d'autres on va bien prendre le temps
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec la France
on est face à une primaire de droite une
primaire de gauche et puis des petits
partis qui émergent à gauche à droite
donc vous vous êtes depuis très très
longtemps dans la caste politique ça
fait combien de temps que vous êtes haut
fonctionnaire  d'abord il faut faire à
mon avis la différence entre un haut
fonctionnaire et ce que vous appelez la
caste
politique moi je suis haut fonctionnaire
depuis que je suis entré à à Lénatin
c'est-à-dire en
1983 c'est-à-dire ça va faire ça fait
30 un/ers de siècle quoi 33 ans et je
suis entré à Lena parce que j'avais fait
j'avais fait HC puis après j'avais été
au Japon et puis j'avais eu envie de
présenter le concours de Lena pour
entrer au KO et devenir diplomate mon
rêve à l'époque était de un jour devenir
ambassadeur de France au Japon vous
parlez
japonais un petit peu
japonais un haut fonctionnaire c'est
quelqu'un qui normalement doit
obéir au pouvoir politique quel qu'il
soit de droite ou de gauche voilà donc
quand on fait l'ENAT moi j'ai fait
l'ENAT je suis sorti 2e de la voie de
l'administration économique de la
promotion
8385 à baptisé promotion Léonard de
Vincy et ensuite j'aurais pu prendre le
ministère des affaires étrangères comme
c'était mon mon rêve premier mais comme
quand on sort très bien de cette école
vous le savez sans doute on peut prendre
ce que l'on appelle un grand corps de
l'État c'est-à-dire le Conseil d'État
l'inspection générale des finances ou la
Cour des comptes et comme j'étais plutôt
de formation économique j'ai pris
l'inspection générale des finances vous
êtes à jour avec votre déclaration
d'impôts  oui b Je pense que ce serait
difficile pour un inspecteur général des
finances de remarquer tout est possible
déclaration de patrimoine oui à jour oui
enfin des déclarations de patrimoine on
n pas spécialement je le ferai pour
l'élection présidentielle mais on n pas
spécialement à le faire en plus enfin
pas plus qu'un autre administré d'un
autre cons vous avez un casier
judiciaire vierge 100 % 100 % vierge
d'ailleurs j'en fais un argument quand
je vais voir des maires en leur
présentant alors ils sont un peu
éberluvés en disant mais on ne vous
demande pas ça  dit mais moi je vous le
donne parce que je considère qu'il est
tout à fait scandaleux que on demande
des casiers judiciaires vierges pour des
quantités de professions en France
artisan taxi sapeur pompiers gendarme
policier quand on présente le concours
de l'ENAT pour devenir agent d'accueil
de la SNCF et cetera et cetera pour
s'occuper aussi d'enfants et cetera quel
âge vous avez  moi j'ai 59 ans mais je
termine mon propos je trouve que c'est
voir ça et puis que vous pouvez être élu
de la République et éventuellement chef
de l'État et avoir un casier judiciaire
noir comme du charbon d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que nous à l'UPR quand
on ira au législativ ou à la
présidentielle tous les candidats
doivent avoir un casier judiciaire
vierge voilà mais peut-être revenons à
ce que vous disiez auparavant c'estàdire
j'ai été au enfin je suis haut
fonctionnaire et un haut fonctionnaire
c'est pas quelqu'un qui fait partie de
la caste politique c'est quelqu'un qui
normalement est censé parce qu'il a subi
des filtres il a suivi des des concours
difficiles c'est quelqu'un qui
normalement est capable de présenter au
plus haut niveau de l'État d'abord de
gérer l'administration à haut niveau au
niveau de sous-directeur directeur
adjoint directeur d'une administration
centrale dans tous les ministères et
c'est quelqu'un qui normalement est
capable de présenter de faire passer au
ministre des notes qui doivent être
normalement assez concises et très
claires pour expliquer la situation et
pour lui demander des instructions en
lui faisant des propositions c'est ça
comment ça se passe au sein de l'UPR  il
y a il y a un leader charismatique qui
est François Lino qui règne d'une façon
dictatoriale sur son
parti vous avez des assemblée
constituante  comment ça se passe chez
vous  alors est-ce que vous avez évincé
des gens qui tournaient trop autour du
pouvoir  non alors déjà le coup du
leader charismatique faudrait savoir
parce que j'ai depuis que j'ai créé
l'UPR y a il y a 10 ans euh On vous a
tout reproché sauf d'être charismatique
c'est ça voilà on m' en général on m'a
dit que j'avais enfin je connais des
j'ai vu circuler sur internet des gens
qui disaient que j'étais un excellent
professeur mais que j'étais pas un homme
politique des gens que j'avais un
charisme de nul et c et ça
bon j'ai vu et parfois ça m'arrive
encore de recevoir des courriels ou des
courriers assez rarement maintenant mais
quand même de gens qui sont dans des
zones très rurales et qui me disent
"Vous ne savez pas vous y prendre pour
créer un parti politique." Bon très bien
ils ont fait quoi eux pour me donner des
conseils  ils n'en demeurent pas moins
queeux arrêtons les qualificatifs il y a
un moment à partir duquel il faut
prendre en compte la réalité la réalité
c'est que j'ai créé un mouvement
politique à partir de rien sans argent
sans soutien médiatique sans aucun
soutien politique entre-temps j'avais
fait du cabinet ministériel et puis vous
allez peut-être me poser des questions
là-dessus et puis je m'étais rapproché
de la sphère politique ça c'est tout à
fait exact mais j'ai rompu avec les gens
que j'avais
connu je n'ai pas eu moindre soutien
politique j'aurais même plutôt eu plutôt
eu des des entraves à à mon à mon action
et donc j'ai fait ce mouvement politique
normalement je n'aurais dû arriver à
rien voilà tout le monde m'a dit "Vous
n'arriverez à rien." Quand j'ai créé
l'UPR le 25 mars 2007 madame
Marie-France Garot que je connaissais
pas beaucoup mais un petit peu je
l'avais vu ici ou là je lui avais
proposé de venir à au congrès fondateur
de l'UPR le 25 mars 2007 j'espérais que
ça donnerait un petit peu de lustre à ce
et je l'avais eu au téléphone et elle
m'a dit "Non monsieur je ne viendrai pas
à votre congrès." Alors j'avais dit 1
heure au téléphone hein j'ai dit
"Pourquoi ?" Elle m'a dit "Parce que
vous n'arriverez à rien." J'ai je lui
dis "Ben je vous remercie de ces
encouragements qui me vont droite au
cœur." Elle me dit "Mais ne le prenez
pas mal." Je dis "Non je prendrai très
bien mais pourquoi est-ce que je
n'arriverai à rien ?"
et elle m'a répondu parce que monsieur
on ne peut plus créer de parti politique
en France parce que vous n'aurez ni
l'argent ni les médias de fait n'a pas
eu l'argent je ne suis financé que par
les gens qui me font confiance que par
les Français et le moins qu'on peut dire
c'est je n'ai pas les grands médias je
commence à avoir maintenant on commence
à avoir des médias régionaux combien
vous gagnez d'argent net  euh par l'UPR
0 € par Luper 0 par mon salaire j'ai un
salaire de vous fonctionnaire d'ailleurs
en je suis pas là pour faire pleurer sur
mon sort parce que j'ai combien combien
j'ai pas très envie de le dire ah bah il
faut le dire non j'ai pas spécialement
envie de le dire mais c'est un salaire
que d'ailleurs que tout à fait facile à
trouver en tout cas sachez que c'est
nettement moins que 10000 € et que et
c'est nettement plus que 5000
la vraie vérité vous savez quoi  la
vraie vérité c'est qu'on m'a retiré mes
primes et les primes dans la haute
fonction publique c'est un moment
important de c'est pour voilà et on m'a
retiré mes primes j'ai un chef de
service par exemple qui m'a retiré mes
primes au moment des
élections comment dirais-je européennes
parce que j'avais mis j'étais candidat
té et puis j'avais mis mon nom François
Sino inspecteur général des finances
voilà et euh normalement il faut mettre
sa
profession mais euh moi elle m'a appris
je ne le savais pas que paraît-il il y a
une déontologie à l'inspection qui est
de ne pas mettre sa profession voilà
enfin qu'il faut j'aurais dû mettre
alors maintenant je mets euh al j'étais
candidat au régional j'ai mis que
j'étais haut fonctionnaire voilà donc je
suis plus plus vague que que ça voilà
donc on en était on en était à peu
charismatique on a quand quand sur
internet on on nous a objecté nous de
recevoir François Lino alors on a
répondu qu'on recevait qui on voulait
quand on voulait hm euh mais on nous a
reproché euh de recevoir euh un
confusionniste qui euh propager les
complots partout euh qui n'aidait pas
euh l'internet à avancer qu'est-ce que
vous avez à répondre à ces gens-là  ben
d'abord ces gens-là euh qui sont Oui qui
sont-ils  qui sont les gens qui parlent
de confusionnisme  hein  moi s'il y a
bien quelque chose que j'ai apporté me
semble-t-il c'est justement de préciser
et de faire de chasser la confusion vous
savez il y a des gens qui me traitent de
gourou et de secte
il faut porter plainte alors oui mais
c'est difficile de porter plainte hein
parce que d'abord euh enfin on en
reparlera si vous voulez mais
juridiquement il y a des c'est assez
difficile si c'est mais
secte et gourou moi j'ai regardé ce que
c'était qu'une secte et un gourou hein
donc je me suis renseigné c'est il y a
un organisme interministériel qui
s'appelle la Mivilude mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
dérives sectaires je dis qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une secte et qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un gourou  une secte la
caractéristique numéro 1 d'une secte
c'est que c'est une un organisme une
association un groupe un groupe humain
qui affaiblit le sens critique de ces
adhérents le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que l'UPR c'est exactement le
contraire c'est-à-dire je passe depuis
10 ans mon temps à donner le maximum
d'informations à tous les gens qui
m'écoutent qui me font confiance pour
affuter leur sens critique pour qu'il
découvre par exemple un par un les
articles des traités européens
lancé contre vous bien sûr et je termine
mon propos premièrement une secte c'est
ça ça affute normalement ça doit
affaiblir le sens critique des adhérence
c'est le contraire que je fais
deuxièmement la deuxième caractéristique
d'une secte c'est qu'à la tête il y a un
gourou et le gourou présente deux
particularités donc le point numéro 2
c'est que le gourou est quelqu'un qui
aime l'argent et qui se fait donner
plein d'argent je vous ai dit à
l'instant que moi ça m'a coûté de
l'argent honnêtement et comme le contenu
du pédigré que
HC ENA Insur générale des finances
normalement je devrais je devrais être
dans une grande banque française et
gagner des sommes inimaginables hein
c'est quoi une somme inimaginable Nous
sommes inimaginable c'est Frédéric Oudea
inspecteur général des finances comme
moi qui est à la tête de la société
générale président et aller voir les
échos ou je raconte pas quelque chose de
très de très indiscret puisque c'est
dans sur la place publique challenge ou
les échos je crois qu'il gagne quelque
chose comme 260000 € par mois voilà
voilà une bruttil une bruttil
personnellement je trouve que ce genre
de salaire est est assez indécent et
assez scandaleux à partir de combien un
salaire devient indécent  moi je trouve
que un salaire devient indécent à partir
de
quoi je
[Musique]
dirais je trouve qu'au-delà de au-delà
de 40000 € 50000 € par mois ça fait ça
fait quand même beaucoup là
net net euh je trouve que 50000 €
c'était d'ailleurs je crois euh 30000 €
40000 € c'est à mon avis c'est le le
salaire que gagne les dirigeants de
grandes entreprises publiques hein à peu
près mais maintenant dans le privé vous
avez des gens qui gagnent comme ça et
même beaucoup plus bien davantage sans
compter les stock option et cetera donc
vous avez une toute toute toute toute
petite partie de de la population mais
qui se chiffre en quelques milliers de
personnes quelques centaines peut-être
de personnes qui gagnent des sommes tout
à fait considérable mais je termine je
termine encore mon truc sur le gourou
parce que le gourou donc c'est la
deuxième point c'est qu'il veut de
l'argent moi ça m'a coûté et le troisème
point c'est qu'un gourou il exige de ses
adhérents de ses de ses fidèles une
obéissance aveugle quoi qu'il puisse
dire et faire voilà alors moi
excusez-moi mais si demain moi j'ai j'ai
quand j'ai créé LPU j'ai fait un cadrage
très précis avec une charte
fondatrice en fixant quels sont les
objectifs du mouvement sortir de l'Union
européenne sortir de l'euro sortir de
l'OTAN depuis 10 ans bientôt ça va faire
10 ans le 25 mars prochain je n'ai
jamais varié d'un Yota sur ces questions
pas une je n'ai jamais varié et mon
programme politique que j'ai présenté en
2011 n'a pas été non plus n'a pas non
plus varié d'un Yota
si demain je commençais à dire bah
finalement on va faire en fait vous
savez finalement il vaut mieux une autre
Europe finalement je suis un petit peu
trompé c'est un peu excessif on va pas
sortir de l'Union européenne on va
proposer une autre Europe comme tous les
autres ou alors je vais faire alliance
avec avec des gens qui ne proposent
justement pas de sortir de l'Europe ou
bien c'est un mouvement qui se fait un
mouvement de rassemblement national
audessus du clage droite gauche et si je
disais demain bah finalement je vais
faire alliance avec monsieur Mélenchon
et les communistes où je vais faire
alliance avec madame Le Pen ou avec
monsieur Dupignant ou avec je ne sais
pas qui il y aurait 80 % des gens qui
sont à l'UPR de nos adhérents qui
renverraient leur cartes par qu'ils sont
devenus et ils sont extrêmement j'ai
affuté le sens critique alors quand j'ai
vu ça je me suis rassuré je me disais
mais je suis justement le contraire
exact de ce qui est une secte et un
gourou mais si vous voulez bien
poursuivre ce raisonnement regardez par
exemple le Parti
socialiste le Parti socialiste avec
Hollande est-ce que le Parti socialiste
c'est un organisme qui affute le sens
critique de ses adhérents  pas du tout
au contraire il passe leur temps à faire
du blougi blouga on y comprend rien pas
d'ailleurs c'est pareil pour les autres
partis politiques des slogans politiques
vides de sens hein regardez Macron enfin
c'est du délire c'est vous allez sur le
site de Macron il y a rien le type ce
sont des propos généraux du style oui la
France de se mettre en marche enfin bon
rien vous voulez pas nous pousser un
petit cri à Macron là  non non non je
suis pas hystérique mais
euh ça c'est une secte c'est-à-dire une
secte ah bah ça ressemble à une secte
c'est-à-dire c'est fondé sur on annile
le sens critique des gens que que
d'ailleurs que on pourra on va peut-être
en parler mais s'il y a bien quelque
chose que l'UP a apporté sur la scène
politique c'est au contraire d'affuter
constamment constamment constamment le
sens critique des gens pour qu'il ne se
fassent plus avoir bon allez je reprends
et puis attendez et puis et puis je
termine sur Hollande
Hollande et les gens du Parti socialist
fait pareil des républicains est-ce que
oui ou non ils sont attirés par l'argent
oui ils sont attirés par l'argent bah il
faut bien payer les coiffeurs quand même
merde et troisièmement
ils ont tout du caractère du gourou
puisque lorsque Hollande dit une chose
puis son contraire les gens ont prié de
suivre vous rappelez ce troisème critère
un gros c'est quelqu'un qui demande la
l'obéissance de ses adeptes quoi qu'il
puisse dire et faire hollandi dit "Mon
adversaire c'est la finance au discours
du bourget en début 2012 bravo  après ça
il nomme brave Macron il faut approuver
il a dit tout et son contraire et les
adeptes sont obligés de suivre."
C'est-à-dire que ce la réalité c'est que
c'est les socialistes c'est euh les
républicains euh qui euh en fait ont
toutes des caractéristiques d'une secte
de gourou c'est ça la réalité d'accord
vous Françoise Linou vous sortez vous
restez dans l'Europe vous faites quoi
ben non on en sort c'est la quintessence
même comment vous allez sortir avec vos
petits bras comme ça  non pourquoi mes
petits bras  d'abord j'ai pas
spécialement des petits bras
deuxièmement deuxièmement je j'applique
des traités voilà il y a un article
l'article 50 du traité de l'Union
européenne qui dit que tout État
membenément à ses règles
constitutionnelles et ben j'applique un
article voilà point c'est une clarté
absolument limpide je personne ne peut
même mes pires adversaires ça va pas
être le bordel mais ça c'est autre chose
ça il faut c'est peut-être pour ça que
les autres veulent pas sortir non mais
attendez ça c'est un deuxième on va en
parler au contraire je ne veux parler
que de ça mais il y a déjà un point
fondamental qui est très très important
à
comprendre je suis le candidat du Frexit
aucun autre dirigeant politique français
ne propose ce que je propose et je le
propose je le propose pas attention on
va on demande à tout le monde hein vous
êtes sûr  marine Le Pen elle reste dans
l'Europe marine Le Pen vous savez ce
qu'elle fait Marine Le Pen elle est
comme monsieur Mélenchon alors monsieur
Lupan lui il dit "Non non il est contre
lui il va rester dans l'Europe." C'est
clair c'est clair dans le fait mais
Marine Le Pen et
Mélenchon ils embrouillent c'est
l'embrouillamini général c'est-à-dire
qu'ils disent "On on y reste mais si
c'est pas bien on en sortira peut-être
un jour dans fonction des conditions de
température et de pression." C'estàd on
ne sait rien voilà monsieur Mélenchon a
lancé récemment un slogan : "L'Europe
changeons-la ou quittons-la" c'est
vicieux c'est extrêmement vicieux parce
que c'est vraiment pour ratisser l'arge
ce que moi j'explique c'est que l'on ne
peut pas changer l'Europe voilà c'est ça
que j'apporte notamment parmi beaucoup
d'autres choses que j'apporte au départ
ils le savent très bien veut dire
monsieur Mélenchon ça rappelez-vous il
avait
appelé à pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 il disait qu'il
fallait changer absolument changer le
TSCG vous rappelez et cetera et cetera à
20h37 le soir du premier tour il a
appelé à voter Hollande sans dire un mot
sur le TSCG sans aucune condition
d'ailleurs Hollande n'a même pas modifié
le TSCG parce qu'il savait qu'il ne
pouvait pas le modifier vous savez
c'était ce traité qui avait été assigné
madame Le Pem c'est pareil le Front
National c'est devenu d'ailleurs
n'importe quoi puisqu'on ne sait plus
qui dit quoi c'est c'est la tactique
mais poussée à son paroxisme la tactique
des lieutenants vous savez ce que c'est
la tactique des lieutenants on les
entend pas beaucoup là c'est-à-dire oui
en ce moment il on les entend pas
beaucoup paraît-il que c'est une
stratégie pour après réapparaître mais
il vont avoir du mal parce que là-dedans
ça tire à eu et à Dia vous avez monsieur
Philippo qui de temps en temps me pique
un certain nombre d'analyses et une fois
d'ailleurs il était venu il y a il y a 3
4 ans là il y avait eu un une soirée à
Paris il était caché derrière un pilier
il y a des gens qui étaient allés voir
qu'est-ce vous faites là  pren des notes
sur ce que je disais c'était c'est
grandiose monsieur Philippo de temps en
temps prend un certain nombre de mes
analyses et lui il peut arriver qu'il
dise qu'il va falloir sortir de l'euro
et cetera mais au même moment vous avez
madame Marion Maréchal Le Pen qui dit
pas du tout il enf va pas sortir de
l'euro du moins pas maintenant vous avez
monsieur Gendre qui dit l'Europe c'est
très très bien il faut simplement la
modifier vous aviez maître vous avez
Marine Le Pen Marine Le Pen elle dit
quoi ben Marine Le Pen faudrait lui
poser la question actuellement aux
dernières nouvelles aux dernières
nouvelles ce que j'ai vou c'est que ils
disent on va utiliser l'article 50 ça
c'est pour essayer de nous piquer les
gens mais elle dit on va essayer elle
dit on vautiliser l'article 50 pour
renégocier les traités déjà c'est ce
moquet du monde ils ont besoin des gens
de chez vous au Front National mais ils
sont inquiets comme chez Mélenchon comme
chez du Point ils sont inquiets et puis
comme ailleurs vous leur faites peur  je
pense que oui je pense que oui parce
qu'en fait nous sommes sur une voie
ascendante on a eu 1002 nouveaux
adhérents au cours du mois de novembre
dernier là il y a il y a quelques le
mois le dernier mois mois de novembre on
a eu 1002 adhérents dans le mois il
côtise à combien chez vous  la
cotisation moyenne c'est 30 € mais il y
en a qui adè à 10 parce que c'est les
chômeurs ou les étudiants qui sont à 10
€ pour l'année hein et puis il y a la
cotisation de soutien à 60 € il y a
quand même pas mal de gens qui en font
la cotisation de soutien donc ça cor ça
vous avez combien dans vos caisses en ce
moment
en ce moment de mémoire je crois qu'on a
quelque chose comme 1700 € c'est votre
trésor de guerre  oui et là on a lancé
un appel à don pour financer les la
campagne présidentielle et les campagnes
législatives vous en êtes à combien au
niveau de vos parrainages  ça je ne vous
le dirai pas parce que ça c'est un c'est
quelque chose que nous considérons comme
tout à fait stratégique ce que je vais
vous dire c'est ce que je dis à tout le
monde c'est-à-dire que nous en avons
beaucoup
beaucoup  non mais c'est quoi beaucoup
et ben beaucoup ça veut dire beaucoup
moi je suis pas je suis pas un menteur
ah oui on a plus de 100 je suis pas un
menteur euh en 2011 on avait 700
adhérents c'était pourquoi ne pas le
dire  pourquoi ce manque de pour une
parce que Non non non parce que c'est
pour une raison très simple si je disais
par exemple que j'en qu'on en avait 80
mais nous démarche on dit baisserait les
bras bon c'est fini on y arrivera jamais
et si je disais et qu'on en avait 520 et
le démarcheur il baisserait c'est bon
mais moi ce que je ce que je dans tous
les cas il baisserait les bras en plus
de ça je rappelle que pour l'instant
nous ne cherchons comme tout le monde
nous ne pouvons obtenir que des
promesses de parrainage ce sont pas les
parrainages officiels les de pèrinages
officiels sont envoyés par le Conseil
constitutionnel le 20 février prochain
et il y a jusqu'au 15 mars je crois pour
que les maire ou les élus qui ont le
pouvoir de parrainage renvoie et donc
nous on ne connaît pas le taux de
transformation c'est-à-dire parmi ceux
qui nous ont donné une promesse quels
sont ceux qui vont effectivement
concrètement la la l'honorer normalement
normalement d'après ce que l'on me dit
il y a en général plus de 90 % des gens
qui honorent leurs promesses mais enfin
bon si vous voulez ça veut dire qu'il
faut en avoir davantage voilà bon alors
ça y est on a les parrainages
non pas du tout on n pas Non non on n
pas les pas je suis présexpliqué
on va se mettre dans le cas de figure on
en a beaucoup je pense que si on
continue on a des démarcheurs à travers
toute la France si on continue à se rite
je pense que en effet j'aurai les
parinages et je pe et je et je ne suis
pas on a touchez du bois il y a du bois
à côté de vous là faut toucher du bois
voilà je ne suis pas superstitieux
euh quand j'entends on a entendu il y a
il y a deux tr jours
madame comment elle s'appelle  madame
Michel Alie qui a dit qu'elle a environ
250 parrainages excusez-moi ça c'est un
mensonge et hanté parce que nous quand
on est sur le terrain nous on sait quels
sont les quels sont les candidats sur le
terrain qui cherche on s'en fout des
autres on va parler on va imaginer là ça
y est vousz 500 vous êtes dans la course
tout va bien ça se
passe vous comptez faire combien aux
élections présidentielles
je pense là aussi en conscience je pense
que si je suis candidat je pense que je
vais faire un gros score fou un score à
deux chiffres
je pense que je ferai un score qui
surprendra ce que je pense d'accord
comment ça se fait que vous expliquez
que votre stratégie numérique est si
pourrie  et qu'est-ce que ça ma
stratégie numérique  vot taux de retour
ça fait 3 ans que vous êtes sur internet
j'en ai mangé des conférences de
François Azino avant de vous recevoir et
je vous jure que j'en ai mangé
qui t'a à faire il y a des trucs très
intéressants il y a des trucs beaucoup
moins
euh vous avez pas je vois la stratégie
de Mélenchon sur les réseaux il a été
euh moissonné un peu partout sur les
différentes communautés qui existent sur
internet et vous ne vous arrivez pas à
grossir sur les réseaux vous avez
combien d'abonnés sur votre chaîne
YouTube  45000 50000  écoutez moi ce que
je sais c'est que pourquoi vous d'abord
je ne partage pas votre point de vue
selon lequel il y aurait des choses qui
seraient sans intérêt dans mes
conférences deement tout était
achetément deuxièmement nous avons notre
site internet upfr est quand même le
site le plus consulté de tous les partis
politiques français d'après Alexa
Hanking troisièmement nous avons sur
YouTube on a plus de 7 millions de vues
ce qui est quand même pas mal euh
quatrièmement ben on se développe euh
voilà et et on est Alors vous me parlez
de Mélenchon effectivement depuis
quelques semaines Mélenchon fait une
percée si j'ai bien compris d'ailleurs
en disant tout est n'importe quoi en
faisant de la le de du de la démagogie
pure et sainte je peux pas vous laisser
dire ça non non il a un contact et non
j'ai mangé toutes les vidéos de
Mélenchon je peux pas vous laisser dire
ça écoutez moi je vais vous en parler de
Mélenchon quelqu'un qui nous dit vous
avez vu ces vidéos  ouais quelqu'un qui
dit l'Europe changeonsla ou quittons là
déjà moi j'arrête parce qu'on ne peut
pas changer l'Europe et il le sait
parfaitement il y a un article qui est
l'article 48 du traité de l'Union
européenne qui montre qu'on ne peut pour
changer les traités il faut l'unanimité
des Étatsmembres voilà donc si vous
voulez mettre une taxe tobine sur les
transactions financières déjà le
Luxembourg s'y opposera terminé et il y
aura par ailleurs malt chip les pays de
l'Est et cetera c'est impossible on veut
changer on veut que l'Union européenne
soit plus dans la sous la tutelle de
l'OTAN on veut supprimer l'article 42 du
traité de l'Union européenne aussitôt le
Portugal avec la base des assorts le
Royaume-Uni tous les pays de l'Est qui
veulent le paraplu américain lèveront le
carton rouge on ne peut pas changer on
veut avoir un euro qui soit plus faible
qui permet d'être plus compétitif
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut avoir une
gestion de la BCE plus inflationniste
immédiatement l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas
le Luxembourg la Finlande lèveront le
carton rouge on veut mettre un terme à
la directive travailleur détaché qui
fait queon emploie en France des gens
venus des pays de l'Est au SMIC et avec
les charges sociales de la Bulgarie ou
de la Roumanie immédiatement les
Bulgares les Roumains les pays de
l'Estont carton rouge pour s'opposer à
cette modification je pourrais vous en
parler toute la soirée donc monsieur
Mélenchon monsieur Mélenchon ment il
ment il fait croire aux gens qui lui
font confiance qu'il va pouvoir
renégocier et traiter madame Le Pen
c'est pareil regardez la caméra là et
dites-le directement dans la caméra
monsieur Mélenchon et Madame Le Pen
mentent d'ailleurs je leur propose de
faire un débat parce que j'espère aussi
qu'on va parler de ça il y a plus de
débat entre responsable poli Il y a plus
de débat entre responsable politique je
leur lance un défi ça fait des années
que je lance un défi un débat ici
monsieur Mélenchon versus Aselino madame
Le Pen versus Aselino monsieur Dupignan
versus Linon ou monsieur Fillon
d'ailleurs ou monsieur Barbom ou
monsieur Montebourg parce que monsieur
Montebourg aussi c'est la même chose
c'est que tous ces gens ne vivent plus
que d'une seule chose il il toujours
toujours toujours ils disent "On va
changer l'Europe" voilà il propose tous
de changer l'Europe c'était déjà le
slogan du Parti socialiste en
1979 pour les élections européennes
c'était changer l'Europe vivre au pays
voilà ça fait je le montre dans mes
conférences ça fait des décennies que
les responsables politiques des autres
mouvements proposent qu'on peut changer
l'Europe je vous ouvre une parenthèse
euh imaginez imaginez-vous vous êtes élu
président
qu'est-ce qui vous engage à tenir vos
promesses par rapport au peuple  quel
est le contrat  qu'est-ce qui va vous
obliger à honorer votre contrat  alors
ce qui va m'obliger à honorer le contrat
c'est
la guillotine non pas du tout il faut
que les
gens
réfléchissent à la personne qui est en
face d'eux et qu'il se pose des
questions en disant ce monsieur ou cette
dame d'abord pourquoi il fait ça
pourquoi moi je fais ça  je vous ai
montré que je fais pas ça pour l'argent
ça m'a coûté de l'argent et je pourrais
gagner des 100 minim imaginablement
pouvoir non mais moi j'ai été dans les
allées du pouvoir quand j'ai été délégué
général intelligence économique pour les
femmes peut-être mais
écoutez si j'avais j'ai été en mesure
d'avoir d'être ministre écoutez je ça
pour par rapport aux femmes c'est ça
ministre
j'ai été en
mesure d'être j'ai été dans les alutes
du pouvoir si j'avais voulu j'aurais
ciré de SarkoZi ou je sais pas quoi
j'aurais pu être ministre ça ne
m'intéresse pas parce que moi j'ai
découvert ce que c'est l'envers du décor
les ministres tout ça le président de la
République ce sont des pentins les vrais
pouvoirs ont été volés aux français je
le je le répète depuis 10 ans c'est ça a
été la découverte volé par qui  par les
traités européens la France elle est
ligotée par des traités elle est liée au
reste du monde par des milliers des
milliers de traités bilatéraux
multilatéraux par exemple les gens ne le
savent pas mais avec la entre la France
et la République fédérale d'Allemagne
vous avez 300 et quelques traités
bilatéraux des limitations des
frontières échange de diplomates échange
consulaire échange d'étudiants échanges
d'œuvre d'art convention de nombre
imposition fiscale j'en passé à 300 ou
330 bon on doit en avoir quelque chose
comme 290 avec le Royaume-Uni 250 avec
la Belgique on en a avec le Brésil avec
le royaume des Tongas et cetera on a des
milliers de traités bilatéraux ce qui
signifie d'ailleurs au passage que
lorsqu'on sera sorti de l'Union
européenne ces traités continuement
d'exister hein ceux qui disent si on
sort de l'Union européenne c'est la
Corée du Nord on a non on continuera à
voir des traités et on sera en contact
avec le reste du monde comme la Suisse
votre sortie de
l'opé ce n'est pas une conduite
isolationniste la Suisse la Suisse n'est
pas écoutez quand je fais mes
conférences dans le dou à Mass personne
ne me pose jamais cette question ils
vont en Suisse constamment ils savent
que l'Union européenne n'est pas dans le
que la Suisse n'est pas dans l'Union
européenne et ils savent très bien qu'en
Suisse on entre et on sort comme on veut
que c'est le pays du monde où il y a le
plus grand nombre de conférences
internationales par exemple bon mais je
reviens à ce que je disais et le
meilleur cannabis peut-être non je
reviens à ce que je disais je reviens à
la question des traités européens parmi
l'ensemble des traités il y a des
traités tout à fait particuliers c'est
les traités de l'Union européenne qui
eux ne sont pas uniquement des traités
internationaux qui eux nous fixent des
politiques économiques et sociales voilà
et c'est au c'est au vu de ces traités
c'est ça qui a piqué aux Français tout
leur pouvoir de décision c'est ça le
truc et donc moi pourquoi vous je
reviens à la question de départ vous me
disiez qu'est-ce qui assure les Français
que je ne vais pas les tromper  mais
parce que toute ma démarche depuis 10
ans c'est justement de leur donner les
moyens de comprendre ce qui se passe et
de leur donner les moyens de dire ça ne
peut plus durer on va voulez pas
rajouter dans votre programme une petite
ligne  si les Français estiment par
exemple il y a 100000 français qui
estiment que vous ne faites pas
correctement votre travail et vous ne
respectez pas vos votre parole 100000 ou
200000 signatures hop on propose un
référendum pour la destitution du du
président mais pourquoi pas  je je
rappelle quand même que je propose le
référendum d'initiative populaire des
votations qui rien
n'empêchera si tel et tel cas moi je
normalement on a j'ai pas fixé on n pas
arrêté le nombre exact de signatures
mais ça pourrait très bien être par
exemple pour un référendum
d'administrative populaire 100000 ou
150000 signatures vérifiées validé en
mairie et s'il y a 100 qu'est-ce que
vous pensez des civic tech
et si Vict écoutez je ne suis pas tout
personnellement je
je comment dirais-je
je pense que les
institutions de la 5e République
d'origine étaient de bonnes
institutions c'est pas pour rien que de
Gaulle les avait conçus qu' ça me
distingue d'ailleurs totalement de
monsieur je mélang il y a des gens qui
disent une monarchie républicaine et
cetera oui c'est vrai mais vous avez
quand même besoin d'avoir quand vous
gérez un état une certaine continuité et
parfois c'est vrai de prendre des
mesures impopulaires ça c'est exact
euh lorsqu'en 1900 donc la gauche
pendant les années 60 avait dit avait
protesté contre le pouvoir donné au
président de la République de la 5e
République qui était tout à fait assez
assez assez très large par rapport à ce
qu'il est dans d'autres pays mais
lorsqu'en 1980 c'est François Mitteran
qui est arrivé au
pouvoir les critiques se sont tues parce
que les institutions de la 5e République
ont permis à François Mitteran de mettre
en œuvre un programme de réforme de fond
d'encreble de la société quand même il a
quand même nationalisé toutes les
banques il a nationalisé toute une série
d'entreprises d'industriels il a il a
fait il a aboli la peine de mort et
cetera et il est devenu au bout de 2 3
ans il était devenu très impopulaire
mais la solidité des institutions lui a
permis de se maintenir et maintenant le
problème qu'il y a et et en 1981 82 il y
avait pas un seul français qui trouvait
que les institutions n'étaient pas bien
parce que tout le monde avait le
sentiment que c'était effectivement ce
sont des institutions qui permettent
d'avoir des changements de majorité
d'assurer surtout un taux de croissance
pour faire absorber tout ça oui et
maintenant le problème je pense que
c'est une erreur les gens qui disent la
6e République mais ils mettent quoi
dedans  il y a rien le problème n'est
plus n'est pas dans les institutions il
n'est pas dans les institutions il est
d'abord et avant tout que nous ils ont
des gens qui n'ont plus le pouvoir ce
sont des marionnettes voilà mais pour
mais pour autant attendez pour autant
pour autant pour autant le monde a
évolué par rapport à 1958 donc je pense
qu'il faut ajouter un certain nombre de
choses modifier les choses dans la
constitution réforme profonde du Conseil
constitutionnel parce que c'est
totalement scandaleux la façon dont les
gens sont nommés c'est-à-dire ce sont
des amis du pouvoir du président de la
République président de l'Assemblée
nationale du président du Sénat on doit
avoir un vrai contrepouvoir dans le
Conseil constitutionnel ce qui n'est pas
vraiment le cas actuellement on doit
élargir la saisine du Conseil
constitutionnel à des citoyens par des
espèces de classe action avec mettons
30000 ou 20000 citoyens qui pourraient
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel vous
savez qu'actuellement seul le les le
président de la République président de
l'Assemblée nationale président du Sénat
et 60 députés et sénateurs peuvent
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel
regardez en Allemagne vous avez des des
des citoyens allemands qui peuvent
saisir le tribunal de Carl Schreux nous
on veut modifier également la
composition du Conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel on veut créer le
référendum citoyen c'est dans le
programme c'est-à-dire les gens pourront
effectivement et pourquoi pas un
référendumatoire si si c'est c'est c'est
là qui qui est souhaité et puis nous
voulons aussi établir le vote blanc de
plein exercice comme dans Suède ou en
Uruguay c'est-à-dire vous savez comment
ça marche s'il y a une s' un scrutin le
vote blanc arrive en tête le scrutin est
annulé il est reporté de deux ou 3 mois
et les personnes qui participaient à ce
tour de scrutin ne peuvent plus se
représenter donc il y a alors en plus de
ça
une faudra qu'on en reparle mais on
reprend le le programme du conseil
national de la résistance de 44 qui
prétendait chasser les fodalités
économiques et financières de la
conduite de l'économie on veut tout
particulièrement nettoyer les écuries
d'Ogias dans les grands médias voilà
parce que les quand je dis je dis les
médias c'est les médias c'est pas les
journalistes parce que moi je vois pas
mal de journalistes maintenant et tout
le monde me connaît mais ils ont un bœuf
sur la langue il y a un journaliste jour
qui m'a dit on n pas le droit de parler
vous sauf pour vous taper dessus on
préfère encore vous taper dessus voilà
il y a on a des on a des sympathies chez
des journalistes mais simplement dans
les très grands
médias ils sont ils sont ils sont comme
tout le monde ils ont des emprunts pour
pour acheter leur appartement des trucs
comme ça et il y en a beaucoup donc nous
on veut protéger l'indépendance des
journalistes on veut également euh
d'alerte aussi les lanceurs d'alerte
protéger les lanceurs d'alerte qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de la loi Sapin 2
écoutez moi je pense qu'il faut protéger
les gens qui essayent de faire vivre la
démocratie et qui ont du courage hein
moi je je suis de ceux qui ont dit euh
je l'avais déjà dit euh je crois que
monsieur Mélenchon l'a dit aussi il
parfois je peux dire des choses qui sont
comparables à de monsieur Mélenchon mais
je m'en fiche euh je pense que la France
je l'ai dit depuis longtemps aurait dû
accorder le l'asile politique à Snowden
par exemple et à Assange ça aurait été
c'est ça aurait été voir la norme ça
aurait été normal dans l'histoire est-ce
que vous auriez expulsé la délégation
américaine en de France l'ambassade
américaine pour le motif qu'ils aient
écouté nos trois dernier présidents avec
la NSA  absolument enfin pas tout moi je
l'ai dit dans des conférences il faut le
dire ici alors c'est mieux
quiconque connaît Paris va sur la place
de la Concorde regarde la place il se
met avec la la l'Assemblée nationale
dans le dos regarde dans vers le nord la
place de la Madeleine il voit à gauche
le le l'hôtel de Crion et à gauche à
gauche il y a l'ambassade des États-Unis
sur au sommet au toit sur le toit de
l'ambassade des États-Unis il y a eu un
étage nouveau qui a été construit au
cours des 15 dernières années on sait
qu'il y a dedans des systèmes d'écoute
très perfectionnés ils sont à environ
dans un rayon de 1 km même pas de 800 m
vous avez l'ambassade du Japon
l'ambassade du Royaume-Uni l'Élysée le
ministère d'intérieur de la place Bauvo
le ministère français des affaires
étrangères et le palais bourbon excusez
c'est quand même un endroit nodal bon on
sait maintenant que tout tous ces trucs
là sont écoutés moi je veux conformément
d'ailleurs au programme du Conseil
national de la résistance de 44 qui
prévoyait de rétablir le secret des
correspondances c'est un c'est un sujet
fondamental pour le 21e siècle hein
parce que maintenant avec les questions
informatiques enfin je vous êtes
beaucoup plus expert que moi je pos
question moi si j'avais été président de
la République et si je suis élu
président de la
République je convoquerai l'ambassadeur
des États-Unis en France c'est ce qui
s'est passé voilà je lui dirai nous
sommes des
pays- France est la plus vieille alliée
de l'Amérique la Faillette Rochambau et
cetera bon maintenant entre amis on doit
tout se dire
vous faites de l'écoute systématique des
conversations les public confidentiel
alors de deux choses l'une monsieur
l'ambassadeur soit vous démantelz ce
qu'il y a là soit vous partagez
soit vous prenez vos clics et vos
claques d'accord  point bas point
partager soit vous prenez vos clics et
vos claques voilà et ben vous savez ce
qui se passerait  et ben il prendrait
pas ses clics et ses claques il
démantellerait le truc parce que comme
le disait Charles de Gaulle les
Américains il faut les regarder droit
dans les yeux ils finissent par s'y
faire voilà où euh il paraît que
Emmanuel Kant vous savez le philosophe
du 18 fin 18e siècle à à Kunxbourg
disait euh si tu te comportes comme un
verre de terre ne ne t'étonne pas qu'on
te marche dessus il faut d'abord
rétablir il y en a une autre il y en a
une autre qui est pas mal c'est à force
de se comporter comme des moutons on
finit toujours la gorge tranchée voilà
et ben voilà il faut rétablir de même
par exemple que si je suis élu président
de la
République moi je sais des choses
concrètes he moi c'est pas des et bien
je prendrai mes fonctions et s'il y a un
G8 comme c'était le cas pour Hollande
s'il y a un G8 3 jours après je dirais
mes chers messieurs je ne peux pas y
aller parce que pour l'instant je suis
en train de prendre mes
fonctions de comprendre l'ampleur des
dossiers qu'il faut traiter en en
urgence et je n'ai pas envie d'aller au
G8 voilà qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
Donald Trump
je me suis réjoui de que Donald Trump
soit élu plutôt que Madame Clinton ce
n'est pas que Donald Trump ait toujours
dit paraît-il mais moi je me fie
tellement des grands médias mais
paraît-il qu'il a tenu des propos
misogynes
islamophobe phobe c phobe ça j'en sais
rien il a dit un certain lâché quoi
ouais ouais oui mais enfin vous savez
quand le président de la République
française monsieur Hollande qui
paraît-il parle des pauvres en disant
les send que que monsieur Trump avec ses
plaisanteries là sur sur les femmes
entre deux petites coupes de coiffeur à
9000 € voilà donc ça moi moi ce que je
vois en tout cas Est-ce que si vous êtes
président vous aurez un coiffeur à 9000
€  non non combien Combien vous coûte
votre coupe de cheveux  ben je suis un
coiffeur de quartier tout simplement
combien ça vous coûte  oh ça me coûte à
peu près 15 € c'est pas très cher un
petit truc de quartier voilà
je suis pas je suis pas un je suis pas
vousz j'ai pas de relaxe il y a des gens
qui disent à 50 ans non je suis pas
quelqu'un mais vous me parlez vous vous
sautez du cocalan c'est fait exprès je
suis pas quelqu'un qui intéressé par
l'argent je suis je suis au
fonctionnaire vous m'avez posé des
questions indiscrètes sur mon sur mes
revenus vous avez combien de femmes
vous êtes marié  je suis marié j'ai
depuis combien de temps  je suis marié
nous sommes mariés depuis 1989 voilà
donc et je m'entends très très bien avec
ma femme voilà j'ai la chance une seule
une seule parce que plusieurs femmes ça
coûte très cher je n'ai je n'ai pas de
maîtresse j'ai une femme j'ai deux
enfants je suis heureux en ménage bon
allez revenons à Trump revenons à Trump
euh
Trump il a dit des choses assez
incroyables pour un président élu des
États-Unis lesquels  alors premièrement
il a dit que l'OTAN était une structure
obsolète et puis il a dit il y a
quelques jours que avec lui le les
États-Unis arrêteraient de déstabiliser
les pays du monde entier excusez moi je
je ne lui je ne fais pas euh je ne lui
prête pas le bon dieu sans confession on
va voir mais à tout prendre c'est quand
même tout à fait incroyable c'est quand
même tout à fait nouveau nous on veut
sortir de l'OTAN je préfère avoir un
président élu des États-Unis qui disent
que l'OTAN est une structure obsolète et
qui va arrêter de déstabiliser les les
pays du monde plutôt que quelqu'un comme
madame Clinton qui était parti pour
faire la guerre à la Russie il a dit
qu'il était contre le TAFTA je ne peux
que m'en réjouir on est contre le TAFTA
il a dit que c'était Obama et Madame
Clinton qui était contre Daesh et qui
était derrière l'affaire de Daesh et
Isis via Arabie Saoudite et Qatar
interposé je ne cesse de dire la même
chose d'ailleurs quand j'étais passé
chez Rier vous l'avez on en a parlé tout
à l'heure quand j'étais passé chez Rier
c'était il y a plus de 2 ans j'avais été
attaqué par madame Léa Salamé qui
m'avait traité d'anti-Amérique
imprimaire parce que je disais ça
d'ailleurs cet passage de 2 minutes il y
a il y a un internaute que je ne connais
pas que je salue au passage parce que je
le remercie je ne sais pas qui c'est qui
a ressorti ce petit passage de 2 minutes
là au mois de septembre dernier pour les
2 ans on en est 1500000 vues parce qu'il
y a des gens qui ont dit en fait j'avais
raison que ce soit maintenant le
président élu des États-Unis qui le
disent Et on revient d'ailleurs sur
votre question sur le confusionnisme ou
le conspirationnisme ou le complotisme
d'un seul coup alors c'est le président
des États-Unis qui est complotiste bon
monsieur Trump par ailleurs il a été
pour le Brexit
je Alors que Obama avait fait le voyage
du Royaume-Uni pour en demander aux
britanniques de ne pas sortir du de
l'Union européenne moi je me dis ben si
je suis élu président des États-Unis il
vaut mieux avoir président de président
de la République française il vaut mieux
avoir un président des
États-Unis qui est été pour le Brexit et
qui donc à priori s'opposera moins au
Frexit et le fait qu'il ait dans son
dans son gouvernement des gens qui
militent pour le créationnisme
alors je vois
que je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure moi
je ne lui prête pas le bon Dieu sans
confession je ne sais pas qui c'est je
ne sais pas qui c'est je vois qu'il a
dans son entourage il vient de nommer
comme secrétaire au trésor un type de
chez Goldman Sax bon le pied voilà il
vient il a dit que finalement il allait
pas poursuivre Madame Clinton bon il a
il a nommé au
Pentagone un un militaire blanchi sous
le harnet qui qui paraît-il fait
l'unanimité pour lui
donc il y a une possibilité que tout à
fait tout à fait vraisemblable que en
définitive tout ça c été un peu des des
mélanchonades des trucs comme ça et puis
que au bout du compte ça c'est gratuit
c'était gratuit la mélang un truc qui un
truc qui qui non mais c'était comment
voilà c'est après il y a plus rien
c'est-à-dire ça fait ça fait pit donc
c'est possible que ce soit ça et puis on
se rend compte dans un an ou deux
finalement le changement d'homme n'a pas
changé grand-chose parce Il y a des
structures il y a des il y a des il y a
des a des cercles de pouvoir il y a des
lobby aux États-Unis d'Amérique qui sont
extrêmement intenses qui s'implique et
que le poids de l'oligarchie financière
l'oligarchie du complexe militaire
industriel et cetera est tel que le
président des États-Unis n'a pas le
pouvoir ça c'est possible donc moi je ne
suis pas là à chanter les louanges de de
Donald Trump je dis simplement que on va
voir et que ça change quand même un
petit peu l'eau du bassin parce que le
type il a fait fortune personnelle donc
a priori il sera pas corrompu jusqu'à
l'os comme le couple Clinton a priori
c'est c'est lui qui corrompe c'est pas
c'est pas lui qui corrompe ils ont ils
ont un peu de pognon quand même la
famille Clinton avec la fondation
Clinton ils s'en sont mis plein des
fouilles ça c'est vrai donc le lui il a
fait fortune deuxièmement il a 70 ans
troisièmement tous les médias lui ont
craché dessus je rappelle que sur les
200 plus grands journaux aux États-Unis
il y en a 197 qui avaient appelés à
voter pour Madame Clinton et un qui
avait appelé à voter pour Donald Trump
ce qui me le rend plutôt sympathique
d'ailleurs plus de 85 % des dons ont
fait par les par les plus grands
milliardaires américains et c'était pour
Madame Clinton
le type il a été traîné dans la boue et
il vient l'homme le plus puissant du
monde il devient l'homme le plus
puissant du monde donc je pense que moi
je trouve ça à mon avis je pense mais
peut-être que je me trompe mais je pense
qu' cet homme doit être dans le la
psychologie de vouloir changer les
choses et voilà alors maintenant
maintenant je ne sais pas encore une
fois je pense il y a des choses chez le
personnage qui me paraissent dingo ça je
suis d'accord il y a des choses qui me
qui me paraissent mais est-ce que c'est
de la provocation  je pense que c'est un
type un
peu un peu un peu flant un peu comme ça
et qui je pense que Vladimir Poutine bah
Vladimir Poutine moi je pense que c'est
je pense très enfin c'est même sûr
maintenant que l'histoire universelle
retiendra que Vladimir Poutine est un
très grand dirigeant de la Russie voilà
Vladimir Poutine je rappelle que l'Union
soviétique s'est désintégré
89-91 euh que lorsque l'Union Soviétique
s'est désintégré la Fédération de Russie
euh avait en 91 elle a perdu donc
l'empire des Dzars c'est c'est c'est
désintégré et Romanov euh l'empire Oui
l'empire des des des Romanovs qu' avait
été constitué au cours des siècles c'est
un drame c'est un drame géopolitique
considérable pour pour la Russie
d'ailleurs les États-Unis ont mis ont
mis tout ce qu'il fallait pour faciliter
cette désintégration qui a tué Ras
Poutine  la Fédération tu as tué
Raspoutine vous savez où ça s'est passé
l'assassinat de Raspoutine  dans une
petite cour  non au sous-sol du palais
du prince Youusov oui eu le temps de
sortir quand même il a eu le temps de
sortir mais à ce moment-là il s'est
relevé donc c'est c'est Il a mangé ou il
a pas mangé les biscuits au cananur  non
il paraît qu'il a tout mangé non il
mangeait pas de sucre ça fait partie du
Ah il paraît qu'on Bah en tout cas il
paraît qu'il eh Ouais s'égare un peu là
ouais ouais ouais faut connaître
l'histoire monsieur Aslino quand même
hein ah ben moi ce que j'ai lu il a
mangé des trucs auurion ça n'a pas eu
des fêtes donc à ce moment-là ils l'ont
mis dans roulé dans un tapis et ils lui
ont tapé dessus et puis après ils sont
allés le balancer dans la Neva et puis
bon allez et puis comme la Neva était
pas suffisamment gelée bon on va
terminer donc bon Vladimir Poutine on
peut parler de Poutine  oui la
Fédération de Russie en
1991 après la désintégration de l'URSS
il n'y a plus que 150 millions
d'habitants
bon entre 1991
et 2005
2003 la population de la Fédération de
Russie va dépasser de 150 à 135 millions
d'habitants c'est ils perdent 10 % de la
population par surmortalité par
effondrement de la natalité par
immigration voilà donc un pays qui perd
10 % de sa population en l'espace de 15
ans c'est quand même incroyable imaginez
que la France passe de 65 millions à 58
millions d'habitants en 15 ans vous
imaginez au passage avec l'effondrement
du chiffre d'affaires enf du pardon du
produit intérieur brut le produit
intérieur brut français c'est combien
ça doit être quelque chose comme je sais
pas 2200 milliards d'euros quelque chose
comme ça à peu près et la dette
française 90 % de de du PIB à peu près
90 92 et quand on prend toutes les
dettes associées c'est combien
publique d'être privé ah alors là on
doit être mais la dette privée en France
la dette des ménages des entreprises
c'est beaucoup moindre qu'aux États-Unis
hein donc ça doit être quelque chose du
style je sais pas il faut peut-être
rajouter vous me posez une colle là tout
à traque peut-être 40 % pour le pour la
dette en plus pas mal pas mal vous êtes
chiffre ça vous êtes le seul de la
journée à avoir eu les chiffres les plus
les plus proches c'est bien revenons à
pe con aussi en général euh même quand
même quand je les connais pas bien j'ai
quand même des idées des grandes idées à
l'esprit alors Poutine qu'à faire
Poutine non mais j'ai des bon
Poutine qu'on le veuille ou non ce type
est en train de redresser son pied tout
à l'ure maintenant la démographie est en
est grimpe en flèche moi je suis allé en
URSS en 85 en sortant de l'ENAT avec des
amis j'avais passé 3 semaines on était à
l'époque il était obligatoire de passer
par un organisme donc on était allé
passer par l'organisme Spoutnik c'était
pour les moins de 35 ans sinon c'était
ligne touriste euh on était allé à
Leningrad comme on disait à l'époque
Moscou à à Odessa et à Kief
euh allez on Gorbach venait d'arriver au
pouvoir gorbachov venait d'arriver au
pouvoir il est arrivé le 11 mars 85 au
pouvoir l'occident à l'époque avait très
peur parce que c'était un type qui avait
58 ans qui succédait au vieill arcoshim
qu' avait eu entre POV Chernenko et tout
et autres il avait été à la tête du KGB
et les gens se sont dit en Occident il
est entré il va resserrer les boulons
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il avait commencé
à faire il avait lancé une grande
campagne antialcoolique moi je suis allé
en juillet 85 en URSS
et euh
honnêtement quand j'ai quand on allait
là-bas on avait l'impression d'un pays
un peuple sans futur enfin une espèce de
de tristesse
qui sointait de partout l'idée que
l'idée que en fait c'est on avait volé à
ce peuple son avenir il était dans la
construction du socialisme on avait le
droit de critiquer les choses hein mais
c'était une idéologie enfin tout le
monde connaît ça mais ça avait voilà les
gens n'avaient pas de futur les gens
s'abstrayaient de le du réel par trois
moyens c'était il picolaient justement
d'où la compagne
antialcoolique euh ou bien alors c'était
le gement foutisme au boulot c'était le
n'importe quoi ça a donné de Chernobyl
d'ailleurs plus puis c'est c'est si tout
le monde s'en fout un peu un peu partout
vous avez un vous avez une un pays qui
s'avachit complètement et puis ça donne
des désastres du style ce Ternobyl et
puis enfin les gens avaient plus qu'une
envie c'est de s'en aller c'était
l'immigration bon euh quand vous vous
allez en allez en Russie allez-y allez-y
allez en Russiez allez en Crimé vous
savez que le le mouvement le mouvement
politique que créé nous avons été les
seuls
le seul mouvement politique français à
être présent en Russie pour les 70 ans
de la victoire sur le nazisme moi j'ai
trouvé que c'était une honte moi quand
j'étais petit j'avais un grand-père qui
m'expliquait que si Hitler avait été
battus c'était grâce aux Russes c'est
d'ailleurs ce que disait tout le monde
savait à l'époque c'était avec Herc
Staline et le fait que les pays
occidentaux ils ont perdu combien de
personnes  ah ben la grande guerre
patriotique comme ils disent on estime
qu'il y a eu je sais pas au moins 30
millions de morts 27 voilà à peu près et
les Américains ils ont perdu combien de
personnes  oh 400000 non 300000 bon ça
peut-être vous avez peut-être raison
peut-être 400000 mais aux États-Unis la
la Seconde Guerre mondiale aux
États-Unis c'est c'est d'abord prenons à
Vladimir seconde guerre mondiale aux
États-Unis c'est quand même plutôt le
théâtre asiatique en fait quand on moi
j'ai vécu au Japon j'ai beaucoup circuit
dans le en Asie et dans le Pacifique
c'est la guerre du Pacifique c'est c'est
ça la guerre le théâtre européen les
États-Unis sont arrivés très très
tardivement euh pour en revenir donc ben
moi je suis allé en je suis allé à en
Russie donc en en 80 en 85 donc pour
fêter la j'ai été invité par la Douma de
Sébastopol j'ai participé on était un
petite un petit groupe nous étions trois
à représenter l'UPR on a été très très
bien reçu on a assisté au con au défilé
militaires à à Sébastopol et après on
s'est
baladé allez-y vous allez voir il y a il
y a c'est plus c'est un pays je dis pas
que c'est paradérêt bien entendu mais ça
n'a plus rien à voir la l'esprit n'a
plus rien à voir avec ce que c'était en
80 ça en pleine redance on a été en
Russie c'était l'année dernière euh
c'est un des pays que je conseille pour
les destinations de vacances parce que
comme nous les à cœur on peut plus
les pieds aux
États-Unis allez en Russie les gens sont
sympa vous pouvez faire ce que vous
voulez mais les gens sont très sympas
moi je écoutez moi j'ai été abordé dans
la
rue dans crimé faudrait peut-être pas
trop chercher de temps en temps vous
pensez la liberté de la presse en Russie
écoutez moi ce que je sais je d'après ce
que je crois savoir c'est que les médias
russes tapent beaucoup sur sur Poutine
dans les journaux russes moi en tout cas
quand on les gens viennent de me dire il
y a pas de liberté de la presse en
Russie moi ça me fait doucement rigoler
je le rappelle que le mouvement
politique que j'ai créé qui maintenant
en nombre d'adhérents est probablement
le 5e parti de France nous avons 30
adhérents en moyenne de plus tous les
jours on a fait 1 % des suffrages ou des
dernières élections régionales on a on
est un parti qui existe on a notre site
le plus consulté de tous les partis
politiques français et bien nous ne
parons sur aucun grand média donc qu'on
vienne pas m'expliquer d'ailleurs à ce
propos vous avez peut-être me posé la
question de savoir ce que fait le CSA
que fait que fait le conseil ou ben le
CSA on a écrit cinq fois on en parlera
après bon alors on en parlera après
l'écologie parce que Poutine d'accord on
a compris on pouvait y aller euh
l'écologie dans votre programme ça ça se
situe où  c'est quoi vos grandes vos
grandes mesures  alors
l'écologie la première chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que le programme
j'ai présenté un programme en nucléaire
ou pas nucléaire
euh ça fait partie des trois on il y a
trois grands sujets j'avais dit dans le
programme je vais redire la même
chose les questions
énergétiques les questions d'immigration
les questions de dettes qui sont des des
des très grands sujets et qui sont des
sujets polémiques surtout les deux
premiers qui opposent les Français et
moi mon objectif je l'ai dit je crois
tout à l'heure je reviens c'est de
rassembler provisoirement parce que je
connais l'histoire de France c'est pas
c'est ça peut pas durer longtemps mais
ça peut provisoirement des gens venus de
tous les horizons de droite du centre de
la gauche pour défendre ce que nous
avons le plus cher en commun
c'est-à-dire la liberté indépendance de
la France parce que parce que si on nous
vole notre pays si le pays désintégré si
le pays est transformé en dictature
alors attendez j'y viens non mais mais
non mais j'y viens veut dire que il y a
des sujets fondamentaux et des sujets
qui sont secondaires d'accord l'énergie
c'est fondamental écologie l'énergie
c'est un sujet fondamental mais mais à
l' pour l'énergie excusez-moi d'insister
pour l'énergie par exemple nous avons
chez nous à l'UPR des gens qui sont
contre le nucléaire mais vous contre
laissez-moi parler contre le nucléaire
et contre et contre par exemple le gaz
de chisme on a des gens qui sont pour le
nucléaire on est mal barré mais ils sont
le reflet de la société française mais
la même chose vous pouvez m'interroger
sur le mariage pour tous chez nous il y
a des gens qui sont contre et des gens
qui sont pour on a des gens qui sont par
exemple on a des gens venant de tous les
horizons l'écologie le nucléaire on y
reste et bien nous aurons sur le la
question énergétique un grand débat
national où on montrera aux Français on
fera venir des gens moi je veux rétablir
la démocratie en France je vais pas
avoir je veux pas à la fois rétablir la
démocratie et avoir un programme qui
soit entièrement ficelé partout ça veut
dire que on aura un grand débat sur les
questions énergétiques on y on mettra
les choses sur la table par exemple sur
l'énergie nucléaire on mettra les choses
sur la table effectivement combien ça
coûterait de de déconditionner les les
54  ça coûterait certainement très cher
mais est-ce qu'actuellement nous avons
un un parti qui propose d'arrêter les
centrales nucléaires tout de suite  je
ne crois pas je ne crois pas que ça
existe parce que on a des contraintes
faut être dans le monde du réel on a des
contraintes on peut avoir bien sûr dire
ben voilà on va faire un programme de
tout on va tout changer oui bien sûr on
peut être le père Noël votre positionn
mon positionnelle le nucléaire c'est
quoi  ma positionnelle déjà on reste sur
le nucléaire ma non ma position n
personnelle c'est qu'on revient d'abord
au grand services public à la française
donc on renationalisef où on l'empêche
d'être privatisé c'estàdire on le
réintègre au RDF et bon pareil pour la
SC on réchète ces dettes c'estd on prend
ses dettes pour nous comment les les
dettes à RVA tout ça c'est pour nous on
reprend tout ça en terme de service
public donc on paye les dettes mais on
reprend on verra on examinera tout ça
mais Arriva forcément EDF arriva c'était
l'ancienne pamatome ça n'a rien à voir
je parle de EDF je parle de GDF je parle
de la SNCF je parle de la poste la
sécurité sociale nous nous voulons
inscrire dans la constitution qu'il y a
toute une série de grands services
publics à la française qui ne doivent
pas être privatisés et c'est pas parce
que par fidélité à 1945 c'est par
fidélité à 7 ou 8 siècles d'histoire de
France j'explique que c'est pas depuis
hier que en France les çaouis 1245 les
premiers services publics donc le
nucléaire votre position personnelle  ma
position c'est
que il y a un grand débat national sur
non seulement le nucléaire les centrales
à charbon mais aussi les éoliennes mais
aussi le gazochis et cetera et puis les
Français on leur explique quels sont les
conseils on fait venir des experts
pendant 6 mois il y a des vrais débats
et vous pensez de autres qui sont cont
est-ce que les Français ils vont avoir 6
mois pour assimiler tout ça  mais
attendez on est démo c'est pour la
démocratie ou pas la démocratie  il faut
que les Français on leur a m cons par
exemple sur le nucléaire c'est très
gentil de dire que on va se débarrasser
du nucléire comme les Allemands mais les
Allemands je vous prends un cas de fig
non mais les Allemands s'il y avait pas
le nucléaire français pour leur ventre
de l'électricité ils ferait comment  oui
inversement là ils ont bien relancé
toutes leur leur central à charbon bon
je vous prends un exemple je vous prends
un exemple madame Michu qui travaille
pas madame Michu non bien sûr qu'elle
est pas bête et puis c'est une bosseuse
donc madame Michu qui a deux boulots
pour que ses gamins puissent aller au
musée pour éviter qu'il se radicalise
est-ce que vous pensez que madame Michu
elle va avoir le temps de se former sur
le nucléaire  madame Michu qui a deux
boulots qui se lève le matin à 5h et qui
rentre le soir à 23h30 c'est assez grave
ce que vous dites ça veut dire madame
Michou alors elle aurait pas le temps de
nous découelle va avoir elle aait pas le
temps d'écouter notre va avoir le temps
mais madame Mich est-ce qu'elle va avoir
l'envie aussi  oui oui vous dites tout à
l'heure vous m'avez brocardé avec mes
conférences qui sont très longues mais
mes conférences qui sont très longues on
on a on est on est on est la chaîne
YouTube va être bientôt la plus vue de
France c'est que les gens les gens ils
cherchent maintenant de l'information et
puis madame Michus elle a pas le temps
ben il y aura on va pas interdire les
partis politiques il y aura des partis
politiques il y aura des mouvements
écologistes il y aura des mouvements c
des mouvements ça puis ils diront eux
dans le cas d'un référendum parce que
l'idée au bout du compte c'est d'avoir
un référendum avec et ça j'ai un point
très précis que je voudrais dire
en France le référendum a mauvaise
presse depuis depuis le 19e siècle parce
que c'est Napoléon 1 Napoléon 3 qui ont
utilisé des référendum en fait comme des
plébiscite pour en fait tuer la
démocratie donc en France notamment vu
de gauche référendum à mauvaise presse
moi je veux non seulement créer les
référendum d'initiative populaire mais
aussi développer l'usage du référendum
notamment de la part du président de la
République le le programme à mon avis
des référendum c'est qu'il y en a pas
assez c'est-à-dire que le référendum oui
tel que je le conçois il doit y avoir
d'ailleurs on l'inscrira dans la
Constitution il y aura le référendum
initiative suitoyen on a parlé il y aura
un référendum comme actuellement
d'initiative du président de la
République mais il y a deux types de
référendum le premier type de référendum
c'est le référendum où le président de
la République posera une question en
disant "Je veux que vous votiez ça je
vous appelle à voter
oui." Et à ce moment-là il mettra en jeu
son son autorité c'est-à-dire si le nom
si le nom l'emporte il sera contraint à
la démission c'est c'est ce qui c'est
exactement ce que Dea s'était appliqué
en 69 c'est exactement ce que Shirac ne
s'est pas appliqué en 2005 en 2005 Chira
qui a dit voilà la constitution
européenne on va voter je vous appelle à
voter oui le nom l'emporte il reste ça
va pas moi je trouve que ça ça ça n'est
pas normal donc là il y aura première
catégorie les référendum demandés par le
président de la République où il dira
"Je vous demande de voter oui si le nom
l'emporte il doit démissionner ça sera
inscrit dans la Constitution et puis il
y aura un deuxième type de référendum
c'est pour écarter ce soupçon de
plébiscite moi je suis honnêtement
démocrate je suis un vrai démocrate je
pense que le président de la République
par exemple comme une question sur
l'énergie il dit voilà on va organiser
un grand débat puis il y aura un grand
débat et puis vous le peuple français
décidera est-ce qu'il veut maintenir le
nucléaire le diminuer le supprimer et à
quoi à quelle priorité budgétaire il
veut qu'on atte  est-ce qu'il est pour
ou contre les éoliennes et cetera  et là
le président de la République que je
serai moi je
dirais je ne prends pas partie c'est à
vous de décider et j'appliquerai la
politique que vous aurez décidé mais à
ce moment-là le président de la
République il est fondé à rester en
fonction puisque justement il se sera
abstenu de toute déclaration publique ou
privée qui pousserait dans un sens ou
dans l'autre dans ces conditions il y a
plus de plébiscite on a affaire à
vraiment une vraie démocratie et je
pense que sur ces quelques grands sujets
parce que ce sont des sujets compliqués
dette la dette la dette et ben la dette
c'est pareil la dette vous la répudiez
je suis quelqu'un de sérieux et de
responsable bon quelqu'un de sérieux ne
peut pas me semble-t-il dire on va la
répudier c'est pas possible en revanche
quelqu'un de sérieux peut dire cette
hête je pense qu'elle ne sera jamais
remboursée en tout cas en totalité donc
moi ce que je pense c'est que je veux
d'abord qu'on fasse un grand audit et
qu'on mette devant les Français les
origines de la dette les raisons de la
dette et cetera ensuite je pense qu'il
faudra entrer en négociation avec les
créanciers comme ça s'est passé pour la
pour la Grèce par exemple vous avez
quand même eu des créanciers qui ont
cédé des centaines de milliards de des
dizaines de milliards d'euros soyons
soyons réalistes ils ont il y a eu des
abandons de créance on demandera donc
des aband d'être seigneor c'est ça  oui
on demandera des abandons de créance on
leur dira voilà on veut restructurer
notre dette on va demander des abandons
de créance mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il
faut est-ce que vous allez faire des des
plans de relance par de la dette
publique
comment vous allez vous faire financer
pense d'abord ce que je pense c'est que
la la société
française elle est sans que les Français
s'en rendent compte
elle est surchargée par des espèces de
poids
morts qui sont très importants lesquel
et quel point mort  c'est des coûts
d'abord le 1000 feuille administratif
dont on parle je rappelle qu'à partir le
15 janvier
1790 les révolutionnaires suppriment
toutes les provinces de France et il
créent les départements à partir du 15
janvier 1790 jusqu'en 1982 j'ai
l'impression d'avoir Pierre Belmar là on
est bon là jusqu'en 1500 de jus Non mais
jusqu'en 1982 pendant près de 200 ans il
y a eu
l'état que ce soit le royaume de France
que ce soit la République française que
ce soit l'Empire français puis de
nouveau la l'État les départements et
les communes point barre bon en
1982 les les socialistes ont créé les
régions collectivité territoriale de
plein d'exercice donc on a eu l'État les
régions les départements les communes
c'est une nouvelle couche 1757
conseillers régionaux c'est de la
subordination de vote
en tout cas c'est un poids considérable
on se passait très bien des régions
avant ils ont recréé ça pour des raisons
historiques mais vous allez rigoler si
je si je vous alle je commence à faire
je renvoie ceux qui m'écoutent et qui ça
intéresse d'aller aller sur les ma
conférence sur les eurorégions et puis
10 ans après
1992 on nous a mis encore une 5è couche
c'est la couche de l'Union européenne
qui a vocation à être un état donc
actuellement on a l'Union européenne la
France l'État la France les régions les
départements et les
communes en fait le grand débat qui va
avoir lieu dans les années qui viennent
ce que je ne cesse de dire c'est que
vous avez les euroatlantistes ceux qui
veulent une espèce d'empire
euro-américain qui vont progressivement
dzinguer l'État France le niveau France
et le niveau département et commune pour
faire disparaître la France et fusionner
les communes et les départements dans
les des comptés à
l'américaine allez parlez-moi allez-y
moi j'en ai vu des maèes hein j'en suis
à peine 95 maires que j'ai rencontré 98
% des mes petits des Français sont dans
vent debout on est en train de de
comment dirais-je  on est en train de de
supprimer contre leur volonté des
milliers de communes en France bon alors
que la commune la petite commune c'est
le
niveau c'est ouvre une parenthèse sans
couper votre raisonnement on sort de
l'Union européenne c'est ça  h Comment
vous faites pour l'évasion fiscale
alors et la fuite des capitaux c'est
dommage que vous m'interrompiez parce
que j'avais quand même commencé à quel
dire quelque chouche que je crois très
important alors
finissez le projet euroatlantiste c'est
en fait à terme région enfin une
européenne
région comptée il y a plus de France
d'accord il y a plus de France les Cors
il vont être contents oui corsika
Ocitania Brace Elsas Flanders Scotland
Wales Paascos Catalunias c'est ça est-ce
que les Français sont d'accord pour
qu'il y ait plus de France  bon moi j'ai
une amie euh qui euh qui
euh qui a mon
âge et un jour je la présente euh et à
d'autres amis et je dis je vous présente
Olga qui est
serbe et elle m'a répondu "Non François
je ne suis pas serbe je suis à
slave." Ça existe dans la vie des
peuples et des
nations que des gens voient le pays de
leur enfance de leurs ancêtres de toute
de disparaître moi alors il y a
peut-être des gens qui sont pour moi je
suis contre moi j'estime que nous devons
préserver la France pas seulement pour
nous pour nos ascendants pour nos
descendants et pour le reste du monde
parce que la France est un patrimoine
historique c'est une puissance qui peut
s'opposer à l'impérium américain ou à
l'impérium russe ou je ne sais pas quoi
donc moi je suis patriote je suis fier
de mon pays et comme disait de Gaulle il
y a les les patriotes sont les gens qui
aiment leur pays les nationalistes sont
ceux qui détestent le pays des autres
moi je veux que demain il y ait un Japon
quelle était ma parenthèse  alors voilà
je termine là effectivement nous ce que
l'on veut c'est supprimer l'Union
européenne les régions et nous on
propose et je proposerai des économies
considérables combien ça se chiffre en
milliard s comenz déjà sortir de l'Union
européenne en coup direct  9 milliards
d'euros d'économie puisque nous donnons
chaque année 9 milliards d'euros de plus
que nous recevons deuxièmement sortir de
l'Union européenne ça veut dire que pour
les toutes les TPE les commerçants les
artisans et cetera qui n'exportent pas
on allégera considérablement des
quantités de réglementation d'origine
européenne que les entreprises qui
exportent notamment sur les pays de
l'Union européenne elles pourront
conserveront si elles le souhaitent pour
pouvoir continuer à exporter ça sera
pour eux un truc sinéquanom mais les TPE
les artisans les commerçants qui
n'exportent pas qui vivent eux ils n'ont
pas besoin d'avoir les toutes ces
quantités de réglementation si vous
allez lire si vous allez sur
l'observatoire de l'Europe un s'appelle
Christophe Baudo en 2008 à partir
d'études qui avaient été faites aux
Pays-Bas aux États-Unis chiffrait ce
surcoup administratif colossal à
peut-être 50 milliards d'euros qui
payent sur la société française moi je
supprime les régions je les transforme
en établissement public régionaux comme
du temps de Pompidou en 72 des toutes
petites structures ça permet de
supprimer 1757 postes de conseillers
régionaux françois ma parenthèse c'était
quoi  on sort de l'Union européenne
comment vous allez lutter contre la
fuite des capitaux  parce que vous
pensez que l'Union européenne permet de
lutter contre la fuite des capitaux
présenter la France sort il y a un
Brexit il y a un frexit oui euh comment
vous allez empêcher l'hémorragie de des
capitaux  nous ferons ce qui d'ailleurs
est l'un des Comment vous allez les
rassurer  mais nous ferons ce qui est
l'un des objectifs essentiels de le ne
pas le neuf seul mais un des objectifs
importants euh de la sortie de l'Union
européenne c'est que nous allons mettre
un terme à la libre circulation des
mouvements de capitaux article 63 du
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne cet article qui dit "Toute
restriction aux échange de mouvement de
capitaux entre les Étatsmembres et entre
les Étatsmembres et les pays tiers
sous-entendu de l'Union européenne sont
interdites cet article là c'est celui
qui a été créé par le traité de Massrich
de
1992 qui a été repris dans traité de
Lisbonne cet article explique les
délocalisations
avant sous Vin Oriol sous René Cotti
sous Charles de Gaul sous George
Pompidou sous Cardestin et sous François
Mitteran jusqu'en 92 il y avait pas de
délocalisation voilà ce qui a permis les
délocalisations c'est cet article là
c'est pour ça que Montebourg il vous
dira oui mais France et si et ça ou
monsieur Mélenchon on leur dit et
l'article 63 alors à ce moment-là ils
disent mais on va piétiner les traités
mais on peut pas piétiner les traités
parce qu'à Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne ce dont il ne parle jamais
parce que il y a un organisme qui est
chargé de faire respecter les traités
par les par les par les pays donc votre
question qui me dit la l'évasion des
capitaux ben nous rétablirons le plus
vite possible le la la les contrôles et
mouvements de capitaux je vous signale
qu'au moment de la crise à Chip on me
signale pas merci au moment de la crise
à Chypre les autres pays de l'Union Pen
violent d'ailleurs les traités ont
rétabli les la les contrôles des
mouvements de capitaux on pouvait plus
sortir de Chypre les capitaux que l'on
que l'on voulait notamment vers le reste
de l'Union européene ils ont même des
facto pendant quelques temps l'euro n'a
plus existé à Ch oui c'est ce qui a ce
qui a perm de bloquer les les les
investissements russes à Chypre c'est ça
vous vous ça doit être sympa les dîners
de Noël avec vous sans déconner hein on
se retrouve à table avec vous à Noël
c'est foutu attendez vous allez me
reprocher quoi  c'est intarissable non
je vous reproche à rien vous me
reprochez finalement de connaître mes
dossiers ouais les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent ou les internautes
qui nous regardent est-ce que vous
sourcez tout de A à Z  oui enfin c'est
un peu mon métier j'ai lu un très long
papier d'un historien qui vous
reprochait un petit peu de vous
accommoder avec l'histoire qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez lui répondre  je lui
répondrai que bien entendu quand on fait
une conférence de 3h sur l'histoire de
3h sur l'histoire de
France euh c'est pas une thèse
universitaire ça je suis d'accord bien
sûr il y a des raccourcis je sais que
certains vont me dire "Oui il reprend le
roman national." C'est la grande thèse
hein maintenant le roman national mais
alors
si le roman national ça fait partie de
notre histoire justement et qui a
certains passages qui été un peu
enjolivé je bien sûr et les autres pays
du monde et votre historien le roman
national américain il s'est intéressé au
roman national américain hein pourquoi
par exemple on tape sur systématiquement
l'histoire de France qui a qui a nous
expliqué qui était George Washington qui
meurt le je sais plus quoi 18 décembre
1799 avec 300 esclaves noirs  pourquoi
on en parle pas  pourquoi il y a pas des
campagnes constamment aux États-Unis
d'Amérique  pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
pas débaptisé la capitale Washington qui
porte le nom d'un esclavagiste  pourquoi
ils le font pas  et puis on pourrait
parler de tous les pays du monde tous
les pays du monde ont un roman national
ont une histoire comme ça alors oui bien
sûr dans mon j'ai jamais prétendu que ma
conférence de 3 heures et quelques sur
l'histoire elle était c'était une thèse
universitaire je j'ai cité énormément de
documents notamment de de d'historiens
du 19e siècle euh qui s'inscrivent
effectivement dans une période de
l'histoire mais c'est une période
justement où euh on essaie de bâtir
notamment sous la 3e République on
essaie de bâtir un un peuple français
une République française l'immigration
les flots de migrants oui on en fait
quoi
c'est une passion chez vous de
m'empêcher de d'aller jusqu'au bout de
mon Non mais c'est une passion chez vous
de Non d'être d'être précis d'être
précis et d'aller écoutez long les flux
de migrants comparé aux autres candidats
non mais moi j'ai moi j'ai quelque chose
j'ai mangé du François Aslin pendant à
peu près 10 jours j'en ai mangé jusqu'à
4h du matin ça vous intéressé  alors
pendant à peu près 4 jours nonstop
jusqu'à 4h du matin donc François Zino
je le connais j'ai été fact checké des
trois trucs et bon on s'accordera sur
l'interprétation de l'histoire je veux
bien maintenant on va parler concret
vous êtes président demain les flux
migratoires vous faites comment  un pour
les stabiliser de pour les encaisser 3
pour peut-être les
intégrer comment on fait  alors
premièrement excusez-moi encore une fois
d'être précis mais l'Union européenne ça
n'est pas
Schengen les accords de Schengen sont
dissociés de l'appartenance à l'Union
c'est tellement vrai que vous avez des
pays comme l'Islande ou la Norvège qui
ne sont pas dans l'Union européenne qui
sont dans Schengen et réciproquement le
Royaume-Uni ou l'Irlande qui ne sont pas
dans Schengen et qui sont dans l'Union
européenne donc ce que nous nous disons
c'est que la le problème c'est la sortie
de l'Union européenne sur les accords de
Schengen on demandera l'avis au français
je signale au passage que le contrôle
des flux de personnes est la règle
commune en France il y a des gens qui
disent "Vous voulez rétablir les
contrôles aux frontières." Je dis "Non
ça n'est justement pas mis dans le
programme nous on proposera aux Français
est-ce qu'ils veulent ou non sortir des
accords de Schengen." Mais je fais
remarquer à ces gens que lorsque vous
prenez l'avion pour aller à Gerba pour
aller à New York pour aller à Moscou
pour aller à Londres vous êtes obligé de
présenter vos papiers c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça dans le monde entier hein
d'ailleurs les gens en général qui sont
les partisans de la construction
européenne qui poussent des cris d'or
frais en disant vous allez rétablir les
contrôles au frontières s'il y a bien un
pays au monde où il est difficile de
franchir les frontières c'est quand même
les États-Unis d'Amérique avec leur
passeport biométrique leur délire
général donc moi ce que je dis c'est
qu'on demandera l' vie français
premièrement
deuxièmement ce que moi je veux qu'on
arrête là je rejoins Donald Trump c'est
qu'on arrête de déstabiliser ces pays je
suis désolé mais le régime comme on dit
de Kaddafi il était ce qu'il était le
régime de Saddam Hussein il était ce
qu'il était le régime de Bachir Sal il
était ce qu'il était mais il y avait des
pays qui tenaient la route qui ont été
déstabilisés ce qu'il y a maintenant
c'est bien pire que ce qu'il y avait que
ce qu'il y avait alors donc déjà la
France a prêté mains fortes à ce genre
d'opérations qui sont d'abord totalement
illégal au regard du droit international
qui ont fait des dizaines et des
centaines de millions de morts et qui
ont ravagé des pays regardez là lui il y
a 70 % des gens qui ont f le pays
peut-être pas mais des dizaines de
millions de morts à la région de
milliers de morts pardon j'ai compris
des millions  non non des dizaines de
milliers des centaines de milliers de
morts sur l'Irak les estimations c'est 1
milliard 1ARD 300 1 million je commence
à être fatigué 1 million à 1300000 morts
bon il y a en tout cas il y a eu des
dizaines et même des centaines de
millions de morts euh ces pays
d'ailleurs au passage que ce soit la
Syrie le ou le ou l'Irak ou Kanafie mais
en tout cas Syrie et Irak
c'était dirigé par le parti basse des
partis laïques s'inspirant de la laïcité
à la française et c'est en déstabilisant
ces régimes que l'on a maintenant des
seigneurs de la guerre qui prolifèrent
avec la prolifération quand on vous dit
que c'était des révolutions coloré de
l'intérieur vous c'était pas une volonté
du peuple syrien de s'affranchir de
Bachar Alassad  non non non c'est une
déstabilisation pure fondé probablement
bien entendu sur certaines
récriminations fondé
aussi sur vous savez ces pays sont des
mosaïques hein c'est comme c'est comme
la c'est comme la Yugoslavie bon le
Moyen-Orient vous avez des quantités
vous avez par exemple en Syrie vous
aviez des des vous aviez des musulmans
sunnites des musulmans chiites des
salaites des chrétiens en Irak c'est
pareil vous aviez des chrétiens
historiens vous avez tout ça et des
choses qui sont de qui sont
déséquilibres ce sont des pays qui au
passage n'ont jamais été des démocraties
on arrête de faire n'importe quoi on
arrête de faire n'importe quoi bon donc
déjà si a ça c'est la deuxième point 3è
point on
essae de favoriser le maintien des
populations dans les pays du sud chez
eux parce que les gens qui quittent leur
pays c'est jamais par plaisirin s'ils le
font c'est regardez les pays du Sahel
est-ce que vous vous rendez compte par
exemple qu'avec la construction
européenne on donne actuellement par
l'intermédiaire de l'Union européenne
beaucoup plus d'argent par habitant aux
Estoniens aux Lituaniens aux hongrois
aux Bulgares qu'au Sénégalais qu'aux
Ivoiriens qu'au maliens et cetera est-ce
que notre langue c'est ça  qui parlent
notre langue  qui parlent neutre langue
qui ont des il y a des immigrés
sénégalais maliens en France quand ils
payent quand ils prennent quand ils
achètent un un produit euh il y a ta TV
il y a un petit morceau qui va aller euh
financer euh la Bulgarie et cetera
il nous reste il est déjà très tard là
le donc les flux migratoires et par
ailleurs je alors pour les gens qui me
découvriraient je rappelle quand même
que nous sommes un parti extrêmement
républicain que nous nous n'avons nous
sommes nous voulons rétablir ce qui a
été le génie français qui est un génie
assimilationniste c'est-à-dire que les
gens en France et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui se passe en réalité en réalité tout
est fait pour détruire la République
française tout est fait pour la selon le
schéma que j'évoquais tout à l'heure on
a des gens qui en permanence jette de
l'huile sur le feu constamment l'affaire
du Burkini cet été moi j'ai pas dit un
mot sur le Burkini parce que ce truc
était pourri de A à Z moi je ne suis pas
là pour jeter de l'huile sur le feu je
suis là pour dire à tous les Français
quelle que soit leur origine leur
couleur de peau leur
religion nous sommes tous français à
égalité de droit et de devoirs à égalité
de droits et de devoirs voilà ce que Et
ben vous savez à l'UPR nous avons j'ai
pas calculé précis mais au vu des
patronymes et cetera je dis il y a au
moins 12 à 14 % de nos adhérents qui
sont des français vous ne tenez pas des
fiches j'espère non mais qui sont des
Français d'origine fichiers non des
Français d'origine immigré qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du fichier qui fiche 60
millions de personnes  c'est un fichier
je ne l'ai vu que ce qu'on a dit dans la
presse donc je méfie toujours un peu
mais a priori je trouve ça très
inquiétant parce que l'acnil je suis pas
sûr que l'acnil est donné son point de
vue et il y a des choses qui sont
absolument scandaleuses c'est notamment
l'affaire de l'affaire de l'état
d'urgence constant quand vous pensez que
ça va faire quoi 14 mois 13 mois que
maintenant qu'on est en état d'urgence
il a des gens qui me disent "Oui mais on
voit pas la différence" oui c'est vrai
que à Nice par exemple au moment de
l'attentat du 14 juillet les gens ont
pas vu la différence ça prouve
effectivement que les contraintes de
l'état d'urgence normalement c'est pas
plus de des rassemblement de pas plus de
cinq personnes en public ne sont pas
suivies ça c'est vrai
mais demain on peut aller
perquisitionner chez vous à 3h du matin
et sans commissionatoire parce que c'est
l'état d'urgence donc ça affaiblit ça
affaiblit l'état de droit nos libertés
publiques et surtout ce que je trouve
extrêmement grave c'est une technique
constante notamment de la construction
européenne maintient de la peur c'est la
la tactique du salami et de l'ennui
l'ennui c'est-à-dire ce sont des choses
compliquées donc les gens diront arrête
de me gaver avec ces histoires d'état
d'urgence j'y comprends rien arrête de
me gaver c'est un petit peu ce que vous
m'avez dit avec ces articles des traités
européens parce que c'est compliqué vous
me gavez pas je trouve sa porfique et
très long non non mais c'est parce que
mais oui mais justement j'explique ça
aussi c'est que euh Hitler Moussolini
Staline Napoléon des grands dictateurs
de l'histoire sont renvoyés au rand
guniafier parce queils établissaient
leur pouvoir par la force des armes
maintenant on a une dictature qui avance
année après année par tranche de salamie
vous savez tranche par tranche on voit
pas le truc passer et ça avance par ça
et par l'ennui parce que c'est vrai que
c'est extrêmement emmerdant de parler
des traités européens je le reconnais
vous voulez gâcher une soirée vous
parlez des articles 63 de l'article 42
de l'article du l'article 38 et 39 du là
vous gâchez la soirée mais si on ne fait
pas ça les gens ne comprennent pas ce
qui est en train de se passer pour la
première fois dans l'histoire on a une
dictature qui est en train de s'imposer
par l'ennui et la technique du salami je
vous mets juste une parenthèse je vais
regarder mes acolytes vous avez des
questions à poser  non non bon allez on
va crate ma voix ah  qu'est-ce que vous
pensez des des mouvements politiques
horizontaux de type ma voix et de type
bleu blanc zèbre ou la maison des
citoyens
je trouve que c'est sympathique parce
que ça
témoigne il y a quelque chose de
sympathique et de et de et de
sain c'est que ça témoigne du fait que
des gens veulent se redresser veulent
agir j'explique souvent que
en le mot démocratie ça vient du grec
ancien des le peuple et Kratos le
pouvoir mais Kratos en grec ancien c'est
le pouvoir par la force c'est pas la
même chose que Arqu alqu c'est le
pouvoir légitime un monarque on dit pas
c'est pas un monocrate on dit un
autocrate c'est un type qui a pris le
pouvoir par la force l'étymologie veut
dire que la démocratie nécessite que les
gens soient debout il faut se redresser
c'est pour ça que ces mouvements comme
ceux que vous citez à mon avis
témoignent de quelque chose de simple il
y a rien de pire que les gens qui sont
avachis à ne rien faire et à regarder
une série américaine ça à mon avis c'est
la chose la pire qui puisse arriver à la
République française il faut se
redresser maintenant ce que je pense
aussi et là ceux qui m'écoutent ils vont
peut-être tiquer mais c'est que je pense
qu'il faut quand
même bien
connaître les rouages de l'État les
contraintes des traités internationaux
qui a souscrit qui a souscrit la France
il faut pas partir d'idée générale parce
que ça c'est très gentil les idées
générales mais justement comme disent
les Allemands
toimil leur diable réside dans les
détails moi ce que j'ai voulu faire avec
l'UPR et j'ai pas les draillet vous
savez si vous me connaissiez moi mon moi
je suis plutôt un idéaliste un
intellectuel moi j'aime bien être sur
une plage avec un livre et puis voilà
donc si je si je brigue la l'Élysée
c'est pas parce que j'ai envie de c'est
parce que j'ai envie vraiment de
redresser mon pays et rendre aux
Français leur démocratie vous avez
combien d'enfants  j'en ai deux quel âge
ben j'ai ma fille qui a qui a 24 ans et
mon fils qui en a 18 vous parlez
d'écologie euh avec  oui un petit peu
bien sûr ou qu'est-ce qu'ils vous en
disent  bah ils sont un petit peu comme
tout le monde enfin comme tous les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire ils
font attention c'est un sujet qui les
préoccupe vous faites quoi tous les
jours vous pour l'écologie  est-ce que
vous vous arrêtez de manger de la viande
alors ça c'est pas forcément de
l'écologie ça c'est la mode la mode pour
le jeu combien de kilos  combien combien
de litres d'eau il faut pour faire 1 kg
de bœuf  oui c'est vrai mais bon moi mon
je vous rassure mon programme ça n'est
pas d'imposer le le le la la la fin de
la consommation de de Alors je repose ma
question qu'est-ce que vous vous faites
tous les jours pour améliorer l'écologie
je combats la construction européenne oh
là là oui parce que le modèle ça c'est
quelque chose que les gens de ELV par
exemple il devrait s'ex il devraiit
s'expliquer les gens de ELV les verts
les gens qui sont partis parce que je
suis désolé mais article 38 et 39 du TFE
qu'ils aient se renseigner la course
constante à l'amélioration de la
productivité le fait que constamment on
place les agriculteurs français devant
le modèle sous-jacent c'est le modèle
des grandes plaines de l'Oclaoma ou de
l'arcansas ou de la Saskwan on a un
modèle d'agriculture hyper productiviste
pas seulement l'agriculture l'industrie
l'industrie consiste la mondialisation
consiste à les fabriquer le pourquoi
l'homme le plus riche du monde à Ortega
c'est un type qui a fait fortune avec
Zara fabriqué tous les vêtements
question qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
pour réduire votre empreinte écologique
bien par exemple nous à partir du moment
où on cesse la libre circulation des
mouvements de capitaux à partir du
moment où on relocalise en
France ce que l'on peut il s'agit pas de
se refermer sur le monde mais il s'agit
d'être raisonnable à partir du moment
par exemple où on fabrique en France où
on a une certaine autosuffisance
alimentaire à partir du moment où et
votre coton il viendra d'où  ah ben on
apportera du coton bien sûr et oui de la
même façon qu'on exportera du vin il
s'agit pas c'est il faut pas être
comment dire on n'est pas dans
l'asymptote c'est pas parce que l'on dit
qu'il faut essayer de relocaliser notre
indust une partie de notre industrie une
notre agriculture avoir de l'agriculture
locale on a d'ailleurs tout un programme
sur l'agriculture pour développer les
les on a d'ailleurs chez nous tout un
mouvement parmi nos adhérents qui sont
des gens qui sont en faveur de
mouvements comme la permaculture en
faveur de d'une agriculture bio voir
vous raisonnez c'est-à-dire en vous
connaissez toute la réflexion sur la
nature des sols qui a été pourrie par
depuis une quarantaine d'années par
l'hyper d'hyper productivité c'est
inscrit dans les traités européens que
les gens qui m'écoutent qui sont
écologistes ils aillent d'abord lire
l'article 38 et l'article 39 de du
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne il a peut-être beaucoup de
lobby là-dessus non bien sûr qu'il y a
des lobbyes mais pourquoi  évidemment
qu'il y a des lobby qu' il y a Monstau
BASF qui sont derrière savez-vous saz
qu'est-ce que vous ferez contre les
lobby vous  nous on veut les interdire
parce que ça s'appelle du trafic
d'influence pour la République ça
s'appelle du trafic d'influence donc
normalement les d'ailleurs avant avant
que la France ne devienne une colonie
mentale des États-Unis d'Amérique avant
il y avait en France le le trafic
d'influence était puni par la loi donc
ça effectivement le lobby de Monstau le
lobby de BASF avec leurs OGM machin et
trucs et maïs ça c'est tout à fait mais
d'où ça vient  ça vient encore une fois
de l'Union européenne est-ce que les
gens qui m'écoutent savent par exemple
que les directives OGM venues de
Bruxelles ont été imposées à la France
les députés vous savez qu'il faut
transcrire en droit français les
directives européennes les députés 90 %
des députés ils ont pas eu envie de
retourner dans leur circonscription pour
tel le Macron moyen se ramasser des œufs
ou des tomates sur la tête ça c'est
encore gratuit ça ils ont eu envie il
faut éviter ça sur notre chaîne bon et
ben oui ben écoutez je suis comme je
suis donc donc ils ont ils ont pas eu
envie les députés de transcrire en droit
français la directive OGM mais et ça je
m'adresse ici à monsieur Monttebourg et
à monsieur Mélenchon il y a ils ne
savent sans doute pas un truc s'appelle
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
elle doit pas elle peut elle doit saisir
elle doit enfin la commission doit
saisir la Cour de justice lorsqu'un état
viole les traités ou ne respecte pas la
transposition de directives obligatoires
c'est ce qui s'est passé la France a été
déférée à la CJUA les juges de
Luxembourg ont regardé ça ils ont dit
"En effet il y a une directive au Gen ça
fait 3 ans que ça dure la France n'a
toujours pas transcrit." condamner la
France à condamner à quoi  premièrement
à transcrire la dite directive ça ça
servit à rien d'attendre finalement
deuxièmement à être à à subir une
pénalité de 163000 € par jour de retard
alors 163000 € par jour ça fait 1630000
pour 10 jours 16300000 pour 100 jours 50
millions pour 1 an 150 millions pour 3
ans il faut savoir qu'actuellement au
budget dans le budget de l'État on a on
prévu dans le budget de l'État chaque
année quelque chose comme 150 à 200
millions d'euros pour les pénalités
qu'on va subir de la CJE parce qu'on
tarde à transcrire les directives venues
de Bruxelles alors moi je m'adresse ici
à la fois à ceux qui croient qu'on peut
désobéir au traités non on ne peut pas
désobir traité parce que sinon il n'y a
une sanction alors évidemment certains
vont dire mais oui on paye pas les
sanctions bah oui mais si on paye pas
les sanctions à ce on se met en en
colère et on se met en opposition avec
tous les autres donc on va aller
jusqu'où  moi je veux que l'on respecte
la souveraineté des Français je veux je
n'ai pas envie d'imposer la volonté de
la France aux Allemands ou eur ou ou
britanniques d'accord allez deux
dernières questions puis on en aura
terminé euh Alors avant-dernière
question la guerre contre la drogue et
votre avis sur le cannabis  qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de la guerre contre la
drogue
vaste sujet ce que je pense c'est que
les sociétés
occidentales sont devenues des sociétés
anxiogène et schizoïde voilà pourquoi
parce que vous avez je brièvement tout à
l'heure glissé le nom de Mansu Ortega
qui fait fabriquer les vêtements au
Bangladesh qui est devenu le premier la
première fortune mondiale devant Bill
Gates il a 79 milliards d'euros de de
dollars pardon de fortune personnelle
mais il y a pas que lui il y a Carrefour
il y a aucun et cetera c'est un exemple
en fait les sociétés occidentales le
monde occidental la la prétendu
mondialisation a a eu pour effet de
bâtir une espèce de d'économie négrière
au niveau planétaire il y a d'un côté
les peuples blancs qui consomment et
d'autre côté les peuples pauvres qui le
sont d'ailleurs de moins en moins mais
qui s'enrichissent ce qui est normal en
Asie et cetera qui eux travaillent et
bossent pour les autres voilà ça veut
dire quoi  ça veut dire que vous avez
typiquement vous allez chez Zara une
femme va chez Zara quelle était la
question  ben j'y viens j'y
viens elle est divisée en deux les les
les Français les occidentaux sont
divisés en deux il y a un côté d'eux
c'est le consommateur qui trouve tout à
fait sympathique effectivement de
pouvoir acheter une robe à un prix pas
trop cher ou bien d'avoir des produits
électroniques bon marché et cetera qui
sont fabriqués à l'autre bout du monde
et puis il y a l'autre partie c'est le
salarié lui il a pas d'emploi il a perdu
son emploi on assiste dans les sociétés
occidentales à la montée concomitante du
chômage des inégalités et de l'autre
côté des objets désirables qui affluent
dans les galeries commerciales avec ce
genre de société on assiste à
l'augmentation d'une espèce de de de mal
de vivre colossal en plus de ça c'est
des sociétés qui ont perdu du sens on
fait croire aux gens c'est toujours
l'histoire de la relaxe on fait croire
aux gens que vivre c'est avoir non on a
perte il y a une perte de sens une perte
de l'objet de la ville la gratuité le le
bénévolat pourquoi nous don ça marche
on a énormément de bénévoles à l'UPER
qui retrouvent un peu du sens à leur vie
et même dans ces sociétés vous avez les
gens ils boivent il y a de augmentation
de l'alcool augmentation de la drogue
augmentation la consommation des
anxiolitiques plus 100 % en 10 ans en
France et puis augmentation de la
criminalité donc déjà pour vous me poser
question sur la drogue moi je suis
j'essaie toujours quand on pose des
questions le problème la drogue de son
son le problème dans son ensemble la
première chose c'est déjà de faire
baisser l'appétence la volonté de
consommer de la drogue c'est-à-dire de
redonner aux
gens le sentiment de bien-être dans leur
propre sens vous savez ça fait 4000 ans
que l'humanité consomme des drogues oui
mais mais pas à ce rythme pas au rythme
actuel ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que moi je suis pas
un spécialiste je regarde un petit peu
ce qui se passe à droite et à gauche euh
moi je pense que s'agissant du cannabis
puisque vous me posez la question du
cannabisme moi je ne vais pas vous dire
je ne caresse pas les gens dans le sens
du poil je ne vais pas vous dire que
j'autoriserai le cannabisme mais je me
demande pas que vous c'était la question
c'était la guerre contre la drogue et
bien la guerre contre la drogue il faut
s'attaquer alors moi sur la faire du
cannabis moi j'ai regardé des enquêtes
moi j'ai ma fille justement qui est un
qui fait des études de de médecine elle
fume des joints un peu non  elle fume
des joints  non je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas comment vous Comment vous
abordez le sujet avec votre fille
ben je en fait on en parle pas mais je
la connais je je ne pense pas qu'elle en
qu'elle en qu'elle en fume je je n'en
sais rien je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de
jeunes qui en fument ça c'est vrai je
pense que la situation actuelle qui est
une situation assez hypocrite est pas
n'est pas terrible mais ce qu'il faut
d'abord et avant tout c'est
effectivement lutter aussi contre les
gens qui pourvoient la drogue mais qui
qui est-ce le cannabis  c'est un truc un
peu particulier c'est quand même une
drogue assez légère même si beaucoup de
médecins tirent la sonnette de l'arme en
disant c'est plus très vrai parce que
maintenant comme il y a une guerre
contre la drogue qui est complètement
contreproductive maintenant les
importateurs les contrebandiers de
drogue font venir de la drogue très très
forte oui mais écoutez qui produit de la
drogue en Afghanistan  le gouvernement
américain c'est vous qui l'avez dit  non
je vous pose la question et tout le
monde sait que la
CIA est derrière a été derrière
l'augmentation colossale de
l'augmentation de la production de de
drogue d'opium en Afghanistan qui est-ce
qui est derrière les barons de la
cocaïne en Colombie  moi écoutez je je
pense qu'il y a derrière tout ça comment
les farcs  oui mais moi écoutez je je ne
suis pas omniscient peut-être qu'il y a
sur des sujets des choses que je ne
connais pas ce que je sais en tout cas
c'est que la drogue a été utilisée aussi
pour déstabiliser pour déstab C'est pas
nouveau les guerres de l'op de l'
François on ne s'énerve pas vous avez
déjà fumé un petit joint quand même
la réponse est non jamais non un petit
thé quelque chose  non franchement non
non non ça m'a honnêtement D'ailleurs je
ne fume pas j'ai fumé le cigare ouais
euh brièvement jamais pris de drogue une
seule fois non des petits
champignons non jamais non bon c'est
pour déconner hein non non mais c'est
vrai je vous dis non je suis pas j'aime
pas de façon générale j'aime pas être
par exemple l'alcool l'alcool je bois je
bois du vin vous avez déjà pris une
grosse grosse cuite oui ça ça m'est
arrivé je je m'en suis j'ai pas aimé du
tout une cuite à quand j'étais jeune
quand j'avais 22 ans ça m'est arrivé et
en fait ça m'a c'est très Oui
franchement ça j'ai trouvé ça très
avilissant j'étais malade d'abord et
donc mais j'aime bien boire quand même
un petit peu de vin de temps en temps et
de ça Ouais normal non faut pas déconner
un peu ah ben moi je suis je suis quand
même quelqu'un d'un peu d'un bon un peu
ben je suis bon vivant je suis j'ai
quelque chose Non ça se voit pas du tout
hein épicurien non pas épicurien est-ce
que vous cuisinez à la maison  ouais ça
m'arrive vous cuisinez quoi  oh j'ai
quelques spécialités ça va vous faire
rire mais par exemple j'aime bien les
plats thaïlandais voilà je fais un bon
Ouais je crois que je peux dire un bon
poulet ou un poulet thaïlandais vous
savez avec du galanga avec du du du
gingembre râpé et puis avec Bon on
viendra manger chez vous allez dernière
question un conseil pour les jeunes
génération là une bouteille à la mer
euh le conseil euh qu'il se redressait
se redresser ils ont un outil
fantastique honnêtement enfin c'est la
la théorie vous savez de de l'armée et
du bouclier ils sont dans une dans un
monde qui est assez assez assez tragique
et qui est très très terrorisant sur c
mais ils ont un outil fantastique qui
est quand même internet et sur internet
les gens disent "Ouais il y a de tout."
Ben oui il y a de tout sur les grands
médias il y a rien donc sur internet il
y a de tout mais il y a aussi des
choses qui raisonnent par eux-mêmes qui
se fassent leur opinion par eux-mêmes
qu'il développe la capacité de
discernement et puis le la bénévolence
et l'ouverture sur autrui voilà
l'ouverture sur autrui il y a quelque
chose par exemple dans mon programme je
veux nous on est contre la
mondialisation mais on est pour
l'universel parce que c'est le grand
génie français de l'universel euh moi je
veux je l'ai dit que à la télévision
française sur TF1 on est chaque mois un
grand film d'un grand pays étranger mais
qui soit pas les États-Unis un grand
film indien de Bollywood avec une une
nuit indienne moi je suis allé dans tous
ces pays j'aime beaucoup de pays du
monde vous savez avec internet on peut
se faire tous les soirs oui mais tout le
monde n'est pas sur internet vous avez
raison parce que de toute façon c'est
vrai que la la
la consommation de télévision est en
chute libre mais en tout cas ben ça peut
donner quand même de l'exemple alors si
les internautes il sont sur internet que
vous allez voir ils allent voir Joda
Akbar qui est un grand film plum
bollywoodien ça se passe sous sous
l'empereur sous l'empereur Akbar au
début du 16e siècle c'est les Mogols
contre qui sont donc musulmans contre la
population hou c'est un film moi je
trouve fabuleux vous avez des questions
à nous poser
profitez-en parce que la prochaine fois
qu'on vous invitera ce sera pour les
prochaines présidentielles la question
que je voudrais vous poser c'est
que je sais pas ce que vous en penser
mais je pense que dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui dans les médias
d'aujourd'hui le problème numéro 1 c'est
de respecter la charte de Munique et le
problème de la loyauté donc ça c'est
votre question ça ouais qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous  de respecter la
charte de Munich clairement et la
loyauté  la loyauté par rapport à quoi
par rapport aux questions  par rapport à
la les gens moi je vois des journalistes
la seule loyauté qu'on doit c'est la
loyauté auprès de notre communauté point
bar oui mais la loyauté ça veut dire on
pose on pose des questions sans avoir
déjà les réponses voilà parce que moi
j'ai vu des journalistes ils sont venus
me voir ils savent déjà le papier est
déjà écrit c'est un tap pied pour me
traîner dans la boue voilà donc ce sont
des gens ce sont pas des journalistes ce
sont des petits propagandistes et ben ça
c'est ça qui manque j'espère je pense
enfin la question que vous les questions
que vous avez posé elles sont rudes
elles sont mais elles sont bien parce
que ça était vachement cool he vraiment
non mais vous m'avez posé des question
vous m'avez poussé
dans vous détruire à à cause de votre
communauté qui nous a harcelé mais c'est
pas ma communauté moi je suis pas voulez
pas leur faire un petit message en
disant souv que les gens qui m'écoutent
et qui apprécient l'UPR arrêtent de
harceler les médias par exemple
excusez-moi des
quelques interview mais en revanche il
faut les comprendre moi je je n'ai reté
aucune instruction il faut les
comprendre non mais on les comprend on
discute avec eux on les achéré ils sont
ils sont polis il y a pas de problème on
n pas eu plus de problèmes que ça avec
eux bon passons écoutez François Lesilo
merci d'être venu nous voir merci de
voir c'est la dernière interview de la
soirée et on est content
vous étiez fort agréable contrairement à
d'autres partis politiques qu'on a
contacté c'est aucun problème avec vous
vous avez tenu vos engagements à la
minute près et ça fait plaisir que vous
respectiez l'internet dans vos
engagements et je tenais à le dire parce
que on a eu très peu de politiques qui
ont été courtois avec nous il y en a eu
mais pas tous françois merci merci
[Musique]